Oh,
hey,
what's everybody?
How's everyone out there in internet land?
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is sponsored by squarespace.
If you've been paying attention to the podcast over the last few weeks,
you know that we had a website contest.
A squarespace is a really it as far as like a website that creates websites.
You literally cannot find a better place than squarespace.
It's so simple,
so easy,
so intuitive.
Just point and click and drag and drop all things.
Your average moron like myself can do.
I could make a website with squarespace.
You can make a website with squarespace.
So we put on a contest and the people that won the contest will be announced
today.
Uh,
we,
we chose four sites out of 10 amazing ones.
There were so many amazing sights to even narrow it down to 10 was very
difficult,
but we got these four.
So the four are Jeremy Jones,
which is me.
So chasers.com.
And what that is,
is all photographs of storms.
Really Wild Shit.
This guy just took these incredible high definition photographs of tornadoes and
cloud systems.
It's just a really vibrant and it's simple and big and I just thought it was a
bad ass website and the next one was Claire Horn and Claire is if a is an artist
and this is just a all from Nashville,
works by visual based,
a Nashville based visual artists,
Claire Horn and all just really cool artwork,
but I just like how the website was set up so we went with that one and then
there is a who the other ones,
adk ventures,
which is all really cool wildlife photographs.
If you click on that,
it'll tell you what that one is.
And then goat soup and whiskey,
which is a.
it's a place in Colorado that is a.
it's a at a ski resort.
It's like a,
I guess it's like a tavern or something like that.
Whatever it is.
Cool.
Website.
I really like how they did it.
I like how they layered the pages over each other.
You scroll over them.
They have pooled tournament so throughout on my good side,
I just think they did a great job with it.
So those are our four and a thank you to those people.
Uh,
you guys win a free year of squarespace.
You get a swag bag that includes one of my higher prime atv shirts,
TV shirts with a tee shirt.
Let's me talk t shirts.
Okay.
And for everybody else,
go to squarespace.com and entering the code Joe and the number one for 10
percent off.
Squarespace.
That's Joe and the number one number one being the month of January.
So congratulations to everyone that one.
And uh,
to everyone else.
Look,
there was so many amazing websites.
It's really ridiculous that we even picked for that.
The one that was number one for me though.
Was that a storm chaser?
Shit,
that was me.
So chasers.com.
That's my favorite one.
Sorry.
Sorry,
everybody else.
I pick a favorite.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t a makers of Alpha brain and shroom tech and all sorts of cool
supplements as well.
Strength and conditioning equipment.
If you are involved in any sort of athletic endeavor and you want to strengthen
up your body and improve your athletic performance,
we have everything you needed on it.
We have everything from medicine balls to battle ropes,
ab wheels.
We have workout dvds,
which I really suggest you follow if you don't know what you're doing,
especially in ones that even if you're in really good shape like the Keith
Weber,
a extreme cardio conditioning workout.
It's a fantastic one.
Even for someone who's in really good shape,
go there,
check it out,
use the codeword Rogan and you will save 10 percent off any and all supplements.
With all of the supplements.
One of the things we stress at on it,
we're selling you things that we use.
We're selling you things we believe in and we have a 100 percent money back
guarantee on the first 30 pills for 90 days.
You try it and you say,
this is nonsense.
Just you don't even have to return it.
You don't even have to send them the product back.
You just get your money back.
I'm sure Peter Shift would say that is a ridiculous statement.
You can't even do that.
It's not smart economically,
and I agree with him,
but we do it anyway because we're selling you good shit.
O n n I t use the code word Rogan.
Save 10 percent off any and all supplements.
All right.
Peter Schiff is here.
Cue The music.
Let's get this pop in.
The Internet is a buzz.
People are very excited to talk to you.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Peter Schiff.
How are you sir?
I'm well.
Well Joe,
thanks for having me on the podcast.
Please.
Thank you.
Thank you for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
I have zero background in economics.
I'm a mathematical retard and uh,
I really appreciate people like you out there that can spell things out and
explain what's wrong with this ridiculous system that we operate under and
what's right about this ridiculousness.
Yeah.
You know,
don't sell yourself short though.
Just your common sense might mean you know more about economics and people who
actually have Nobel prizes in economics.
Well,
I would disagree with you,
but I saw that movie inside job and I saw how the whole system works where they,
you know,
essentially set these financial limitations and then wind up getting jobs after
their,
you know,
the economics professors set these limitations and then wind up getting jobs and
wind up profiting off of the fact that they made it so that these things go
through you and your video from occupy Wall Street is one of my all time
favorites when you went down there and he said,
I am the one percent,
and you started talking to just knuckleheads,
knock and I know you didn't cherry pick because he had a few intelligent people
in there too,
but it was beautifully representative of what's actually going on.
This sort of emotional outrage,
this,
this wanting to understand and explain why our economy is in such a mess,
but having this very distorted perception of the actual facts themselves.
Yeah,
and you know,
my purpose of going down there was to call attention to the.
They,
I think they misdiagnosed or misunderstood what was really going on.
They bought into this idea that it's capitalism or the free market that is the
problem.
And so they were blaming maybe Wall Street because they looked at Wall Street is
somehow epitomizing American capitalism.
And I wanted to point out that what they were really upset wet,
oh,
ad was not capitalism,
right?
It,
it,
it was because of government.
It was because of central banking and central planning and crony capitalism.
That was the source of all their problems.
That really the solution to the problems is free market capitalism.
They just don't understand it.
And so I wanted to go there and explain to the people in that park,
uh,
but more importantly,
if people watch the interactions between me and the occupiers,
uh,
to try to really expose how ridiculous the things that they're saying are.
I understood that they were upset and they were frustrated.
But,
you know,
the source of their frustration was misplaced.
I mean,
they shouldn't be protesting Washington.
They should be protesting the Federal Reserve Congress.
Uh,
not Wall Street.
I mean,
what's going on on Wall Street is a symptom of the problem,
but it's not capitalism because when you have the government and Wall Street
working together,
uh,
you know,
that's not the free market.
I mean,
the government that is at the source of it,
it's not necessarily the bank's fault,
uh,
it sure they,
everybody wants something from government,
but the government should deny right?
When,
when,
when somebody wants to bail out or somebody wants something for nothing,
the government should not supply it.
I can't necessarily blame Wall Street for wanting something for nothing,
but I blame the government for supplying it.
Now,
how do,
do they supply it?
Do they supply it?
Because the people that are asking for them to supply it are the ones who
contributed to their campaigns and got them into office.
And then once they get in there,
they acquiesced.
That's part of it.
But a lot of it is the,
the,
the government wants to maintain the illusion of prosperity,
the illusion of economic growth.
Uh,
and so the way they do that now is through the financial markets,
through assets.
And they get the stock market to go up,
they get the real estate market to go up and somehow they,
they pretend that that means that the economy's getting better just because
asset prices are rising,
but that's not really economic growth,
just because the price of some asset goes up.
I mean,
what's economic growth is when your economy produces more stuff,
when you have more output of the goods and services that make people's lives
better,
right?
You want to grow your standard of living.
Um,
you know,
if people are poor,
they're poor because they don't have enough stuff,
right?
So we have to produce more stuff for people to consume.
And that's not what's happening in the US economy.
It's not like we've gotten more factories turning out more stuff.
All that they do is they get asset prices to rise so that people can borrow more
money against those inflated asset values and then spend it.
But we're buying things that are made in other countries.
It doesn't evidence economic growth here.
It evidences the economic growth in the countries who are able to produce all
the things that we have to borrow money to consume,
but it doesn't benefit average American.
That's why the average American is suffering as a result of this massive
transfer of wealth that is emanating from,
from government,
from the Federal Reserve,
and from what was what,
what's happening in Congress in the White House,
but they point to these asset markets as evidence that their policies are of
success.
But then meanwhile,
you know their policies or complete failure if you judge it by what's actually
going on in the economy.
And of course everything they're doing now is just setting the stage for a
economic disaster that is going to be much worse than what we had in 2008.
Well,
you predicted the one in 2008.
Uh,
you saw it coming.
You,
you,
you talked about it on multiple occasions that we're eventually going to have
some large real estate clubs.
W when that happens,
this is where I get confused.
So that happens.
And then when there's a real situation like that where banks are in jeopardy,
what,
what transpires there,
like who votes on it,
who,
who decides and agrees that you're going to take taxpayer money and what are the
repercussions of them not doing it.
So they didn't bail the banks out.
What would have happened?
Well,
it would have been far more painful certainly at that time to deal with our
problems.
It's always painful.
I mean if you're,
if you're a drug addict and you want to deal with it and you want to go cold
Turkey and go to rehab,
that's painful.
It's easier to keep taking drugs,
right?
If you're overweight and you know,
is it easier to go on a diet and exercise?
We'll just keep on picking out and you know,
so it's always difficult to do the right thing in the short run,
but it pays off in the long run.
And so if you want to go back to the origin of the [inaudible] eight financial
crisis,
you go look to the stock market bubble that burst in 2000 and the recession that
began in 2000.
And one,
a lot of it,
you know,
you had the September 11th tragedy,
uh,
and we were going into a recession and,
and so instead of allowing the pain of a recession to play out,
and of course nobody enjoys a recession,
but recessions are actually necessary.
That's the process.
We're all the mistakes that were made during the boom or corrected.
And of course we made a lot of mistakes during the tech boom.
A lot of companies were funded,
hired people,
rented office space that never should've started because they had no real
business plans.
They couldn't make any money.
We did a lot of stupid things during the 19 nineties bubble and they needed to
be corrected during the recession.
But the politicians,
you know,
Bush had just become president.
He didn't want a big recession on his first term because of course he wanted a
second term.
And so Alan Greenspan cooperated with Bush because he wanted to get reappointed.
And so they had a big monetary stimulus.
They,
they dropped interest rates down to one percent,
which is high by today's standards.
But it was a record low back then.
And a lot of the money that was going into the stock market went into the real
estate market.
So we replaced the stock market bubble with a real estate bubble that actually
had began forming a few years earlier.
But it really gathered momentum after the real estate,
the stock market bubble burst.
And so the real estate bubble got all the air and so now housing prices were
going up and because they were going up,
people were.
I thought they were rich.
So they went out and spent money.
They didn't have.
They borrowed it against the appreciating buyer,
their houses.
They bought more houses,
they bought cars,
they took vacations.
And during that time I knew this was a mania.
I knew that the big crisis though for the real estate market was not going to be
the buyer of real estate because in the stock market bubble,
when the stock market bubble burst,
it was the people who bought stocks who lost because they were buying gambling
with their own money.
But when people were buying houses,
they were gambling with the bank's money.
But in fact,
it was taxpayer money because the banks were all guaranteed by the government,
and so I knew when the real estate bubble burst and prices went down that the
banks would be insolvent and that the banks would fail.
Now had the government allowed real estate prices to fall,
which was a good thing.
The problem was that they went up.
Coming back down,
was was reality coming back.
Had the government allowed the banks to fail and real estate prices to keep
falling.
It would have been more painful in the short run,
but it would have been necessary pain.
It would have been constructive pain because we would have laid the foundation
for a legitimate economic recovery,
which is what we should've done in 2001.
We shouldn't have had that.
All that monetary stimulus.
We shouldn't have created a housing bubble.
We should have just endured the pain and then we would have been in better
shape.
So they.
They blew up this housing bubble and now when it bursts,
they didn't learn from their mistakes.
Ben Bernanke,
he just repeated all the mistakes of Alan Greenspan.
Only this time interest rates had to come to zero because you know,
it was an even bigger crisis and now we have all the money printing.
They called quantitative easing,
but we have much easier,
much more aggressive monetary stimulus.
Now we're doing far more damage to the economy.
We've managed to reflate the stock market bubble.
We've reflated the real estate bubble.
We have more debt as a society than ever before.
Uh,
the government has more debt,
corporations have more debt,
individuals.
There's no pen,
no d leveraging.
We take,
we were in a deep hole and then we dug a lot deeper and we've set the stage a
Ben Bernanke has set the stage for a much greater economic crisis than the one
from 2008.
It's going to blow up on Janet Yellen,
just like the Greenspan bubble blew up on Bernacchi.
That Bernacchi bubble is going to blow up on yelling.
It's much bigger and I'm afraid that yellen is going to do more of the same.
Only worse when she gets in and,
and,
and we're in for a,
you know,
a much worse economic crisis because this one I think is going to be where the
dollar collapses and that's going to usher in a lot more pain for ordinary
Americans than the bursting of the stock market.
Butler of the housing bubble.
Back to that word pain because this where what I really was confused about when
you say that it would have caused a lot more pain if the banks had failed,
but ultimately it would have been better because we were figured out what was
wrong and then and not allow that to go.
What kind of pain would that have been when you're dealing with federally
insured banks?
So if the average person,
how much of their money would be insured?
The government,
if banks collapse and then where does that money come from?
If they have to ensure all the people who had money in the bank accounts?
Yeah.
Well theoretically right?
I mean the government now stands behind a,
you know,
the bank accounts.
I mean,
the FDA has a limit,
maybe $250,000,
but the government is,
you know,
bailed out,
banks know when they fail,
they bell at everybody.
I mean,
that's a mistake.
We shouldn't have any government insured deposits.
I mean,
it's,
it's a huge moral hazard,
uh,
because,
you know,
people now will put their money into banks and no one cares what the bank does
with their money because the government ensures the account so the banks can be
as reckless as they want and there's no free market penalty.
If we had a free market and banking like we had at one point,
banks couldn't be reckless because they wouldn't have any depositors.
Depositors would care about what the bank does with their money.
And so in order to get the positives,
banks would have to be cautious and they would advertise how safe their
portfolios were.
And you would have companies that would rate them and say,
this is a good bank to put your money.
Uh,
but right now,
nobody cares.
They're all the same.
Right?
And so you'll put your money anywhere.
How much of your money is insured?
Well,
it's theoretically the government insurers at all,
but you have $10,000,000 in the bank and the bank fails.
The government gives you 10 million.
Well,
it doesn't seem no.
that's what they've done in the past.
They're only technically supposed to give you now $250,000,
but they have given you all of it.
But the problem is only smaller banks have failed so far.
But if,
if a large bank were to fail,
there's not enough money in the FDC to bail out the depositors.
So the government would have to create it.
The Federal Reserve would have to print it into existence.
And,
and so what's ultimately gonna Happen is sure,
we've got all these insured,
Bank du Pont counts,
but if a bit a couple of big banks fail and the government has to print all the
money to reimburse the depositors,
you have massive inflation and it,
you know,
you get your money back,
but you can't buy anything with it or you can't buy nearly as much.
What would actually happen if the government had done the right thing and
allowed banks to fail?
Um,
then some depositors would have lost money,
some depositors would have not got back one hundred cents on the dollar,
but in the long run that would be better off than getting back all your money
and have it not by anything.
And you know,
there would have been paying for some people,
right?
The government would've been forced to cut a lot of spending.
Uh,
the government would have had to lay people off and so that would be good for
the economy,
wouldn't be good in the short run for the guy who got laid off.
Now he has to go get a real job.
Uh,
but the government would have to start cutting,
spending real estate prices would have fallen.
So people,
you know,
some people would lose that home equity.
But you know,
if you,
if you don't have a house falling real estate prices are,
is a good thing for you.
I mean,
the government always talks about,
you know,
trying to make homeownership affordable.
Well,
the best way to do that as the prices come down,
why is the government trying to stop real estate prices from coming down when
they say they want houses to be affordable?
What the government wants is to prop up real estate prices at artificial levels,
so you have to borrow a fortune to buy a house,
but then they want to subsidize the debt so they do the same thing with college.
They want.
They want everyone to go to college,
but they don't want college tuition to come down because of the government
guarantees all the student loans and so that's why college is so expensive
because the students take all that government money and they'd been up tuition
and the colleges know that.
It doesn't matter how high the prices are because the kids are going to get the
money from the government to pay the price,
but meanwhile they graduate.
They've got these worthless degrees and they got a pile of debt.
If the government just got out of the way and they didn't give out all this
money to students than the university is,
we'd have to slash tuition or they'd have no customers and now you can get a
college degree without taking out a mortgage.
Are you aware that famous Putin quote before the crash about the economy wasn't
hooten said he didn't know.
I don't understand the United States economy.
It seems they only buy and sell each other's houses.
Well,
yeah,
that's.
We had an economy that was all about flipping houses.
A strange though,
but we,
we,
we have this service sector economy now that is completely unbelievable,
uh,
because it's,
it's the result of our ability right to,
to borrow indefinitely from abroad to pay for the products that are manufactured
in other countries.
Uh,
but this bubble is going to burst because,
you know,
we can't keep borrowing the world.
Keep,
can't keep lending us money.
It's like a giant vendor financing scheme where other countries produce products
and then they lend us the money to buy those products.
But we can't pay back any of the money we've already borrowed yet.
They keep lending us more because they don't want to deal with the reality of
how much money they've lost.
What,
what kind of an epic change would be involved in,
in getting away from this trend,
what kind of an epic change would be involved in making sure that the government
doesn't subsidize universities,
that making sure that housing costs do go down,
making sure that banks aren't government protected.
What I mean that seems like it would.
It would take an epic change.
Well that it is.
I think because it's
going to take a crisis and I think fortunately or unfortunately that crisis is
coming.
There's going to be a crisis that we can't print our way out of that we can't
bail are way out of and,
and I think that's where we are.
I mean,
I think the bubble that we have now is just so big and I think the,
the,
the Fed knows that it's,
it's so big.
It's too big to pop,
forgetting about too big to fail,
that there is no more bubbles.
This is the last Hurrah for,
for our phone.
Economy goes.
There's,
there's no,
there's nothing left to do once,
once this collapses and then maybe there'll be the catalyst to do the right
thing,
but I think the way the collapse is going to come is going to be in the value of
our currency,
which right now is relatively stable.
It's actually risen recently against some currencies,
uh,
although not all currencies,
but I think that the Fed is going to keep on printing money.
There's an expectation right now that there's a real economic recovery and that
the Fed is going to be able to remove the monetary props.
There is no real recovery and the Fed can't remove the props.
It should,
but the minute it did,
the whole economy would implode.
I think as people begun begin to realize that,
to appreciate what the Fed created,
right?
Not a sustainable recovery but it,
but a bubble there.
The world is not going to want our dollars anymore because the Fed has to keep
printing dollars to buy bonds.
Uh,
so that we can keep borrowing money.
The government can keep borrowing money,
but when people don't want the dollars at the Fed is creating.
Now the value of the dollar starts to go down and that's when you start to see a
real acceleration in prices for consumer goods.
I mean,
and the government tries to deny that there is inflation,
but there's massive inflation.
It's not all showing up yet in consumer prices,
although a lot of prices looking since 2009 mil prices have more than doubled.
Uh,
I think beef prices chop me.
Prices are up 80,
90 percent.
I mean,
look at gasoline price at record highs.
So the government tells us there's no inflation,
but there's plenty of it,
but it's going to get a lot worse.
That is the bad news.
Now,
the government is actually trying to lay the foundation for higher inflation
now,
uh,
by trying to tell us that it's a good thing.
You know,
if,
if you,
if you listen to the economist today,
they'll tell you that the scariest thing,
that worst thing that can happen is that we don't have enough inflation.
That we have to make sure that prices are rising fast enough to have economic
growth.
They used to say that we want stable prices.
Now they tell us that that's dangerous.
That's a bad thing because if prices are stable,
they might actually go down a little bit and that would be horrible.
Right?
So the government wants us to be thankful when the cost of living goes up when
obviously you know,
a good strong economy has fallen consumer prices.
That's the goal of an economy.
It's to bring prices down so that people can buy more stuff.
Is the problem in competent intervention in the market or is the problem that
it's just a system that can't be fixed?
Well,
that right now the system can't be fixed,
it's just going to collapse,
but the.
So it has to do.
In your opinion,
should it has to?
Yeah,
it will,
but there are a lot of incentives to keep it going right,
to keep the party going as long as possible.
The politicians want to keep it going.
I mean they love phony prosperity because it's better than reality because if
the public knew how screwed they were,
right,
they might not reelect the guys that are there,
so they want to keep it going.
They have no incentive to rain on the parade,
they don't want to solve any problems.
Uh,
they just,
they just want to get through the next election,
uh,
Wall Street,
I mean,
they're making a ton of money.
there are people that are making a fortune off of this bad monetary policy and
so they don't want it to stop.
They don't want to deal with reality.
They want to just keep making,
you know,
making hay while the sun shines.
And the academics,
the media,
I think these guys are just clueless.
Uh,
so nobody really,
you know,
hasn't either understands or has a vested interest to understand the truth.
Everybody wants to keep the party going.
That was exactly what was going on in 2003 and four and five and six when I was
going around going on TV shows,
given,
given lectures,
uh,
explaining all the problems in the housing market and how the Fed was creating
it and how bad it was going to be when the bubble burst.
Nobody wanted to hear it.
I mean,
everybody either laughed at me,
ridiculed me,
and this,
this should have been obvious.
This should've been crystal clear yet people couldn't see it.
And then everybody was blindsided by what happened.
They said,
well,
nobody could have possibly predicted this.
Right?
Of course that was wrong.
Um,
but,
you know,
and then instead of,
learning from the mistakes or instead of,
you know,
listening to people like me and I wasn't the only guy that was out there talking
about,
I just did it maybe more publicly than a lot of people.
But instead of saying,
Hey,
you know,
let's talk to Peter Schiff,
he,
he saw this thing come in,
uh,
you know,
what does he think,
they,
they had,
uh,
a government inquiry,
to the financial crisis.
It right after it happened.
It was an investigation as to why there was a financial crisis.
And you would've thought,
Gee,
I wrote a book,
predicted the financial crisis,
crash proof how to profit from the coming economic collapse that described
exactly what happened.
I wrote about it.
I talked about it for years.
I have all these essays on the Internet,
there's all these youtube videos you can see,
you know,
conferences.
Look at my mortgage bankers speech from 2006.
I was like,
great,
why don't I go and testify in front of Congress and explain why we had a
financial crisis.
They wouldn't call me,
of course,
not
say something exactly like you said in the first 15 minutes of this.
Yeah,
they don't want to hear it.
In fact,
I did testify twice in front of Congress later on and you can see those
testimonies are on youtube.
And I was actually surprised that they invited me back a second time after I
testified the first time.
I think maybe some people didn't really realize who I was.
And so they haven't invited me back a third time,
but,
you know,
I'd tell them the truth and I treat these guys like they ought to be treated.
I don't really show any respect for people that are destroying our country.
Uh,
and so I put them in their place when,
when I testify,
but they didn't really want anybody testifying,
uh,
who,
knew why there was a crisis because they already had,
they already had a preconceived conclusion.
They wanted to blame it on capitalism.
They wanted to say we had a crisis because we didn't have enough regulation
because we didn't have enough government,
which of course was the opposite of why we had the crisis.
We had too much regulation and too much government.
The free market would have prevented that crisis.
Now you say that you don't believe in regulation,
but do you agree with when it comes to regulation,
when it comes to environmental protections,
when it comes to things like the EPA or when it comes to like situations,
like what do you do about when you have this massive Gulf oil spill,
do you believe in the government should intervene then?
Yeah.
Well,
first of all,
there are market regulations,
right?
Markets in many cases regulate themselves because of the self interests of the
party.
So for example,
when I talk about banks,
right?
If there was no government,
I'm guaranteeing the safety of bank accounts in order for banks to thrive and
get customers,
they are going to have to,
you know,
provide a safe platform,
a depository of their,
of their savings and banks will compete with each other based on who's got the
safest bank.
Whereas you know,
where's my money going to be secure because that's really what you're worried
about.
And so there is market based regulation.
We're from competition and you get that every place may people say,
well,
you know,
don't we need the government to make sure that the airlines are safe?
Well,
who's got a vested interest in a safe airline than the owner?
That airline,
I mean the last thing a,
an airline wants is a crash.
And the most important thing,
you know,
I fly a lot.
The most important thing to me is that it's a safe flight.
And so,
you know,
I'm not going to go on a plane on an,
on an airline that,
you know,
they cut corners to save a couple of bucks.
So there's gonna be a lot of regulation in the market.
Unfortunately,
what happens is the government comes in and now they create a moral hazard that
undermines the normal market regulation and replaces it with a government
regulation that's nowhere near as good moral hazard.
Yeah.
Well,
moral hazard.
in the bank account,
again in the bank account example,
without government interference,
I care about what the banks do with my money.
I'm not just gonna Dump my money in the bank,
uh,
and not worry about it.
I'm going to do some research before my bank account.
I want to make sure that the bank is sound.
The bank knows that in order to attract customers,
it has to be safe.
It can't just be gambling with depositors money.
Um,
but when the government steps in,
now no one cares about safety because the government says,
don't worry,
we'll make sure the bank is safe.
So now the,
now the depositors say we don't give a damn.
We'll put our money anywhere.
I don't care which bank it is.
Nobody does any research.
I mean,
people do more research before they buy a microwave oven or a television set.
Then depositing their life savings into a bank.
It's just whichever one is closest,
that's,
you know,
I'm going to put my money there.
The banks know this.
Now,
the only thing that banks have to do is convince the regulators to give them a
pass.
But then you got all kinds of corruption you've got and you've got the
government has all kinds of corrupt incentives.
So market based regulation is much better.
But certainly I do believe in some types of regulation when it comes to
externalities like pollution and things like that.
But a lot of that is best done at a local level,
not at the federal level.
And a lot of it is done through courts because people are still liable in a free
market.
So if I damage you in some way,
uh,
then you know,
I'm responsible for your damage and you consume me.
And so businesses don't want to be sued.
They don't want to,
you know,
uh,
harm other people.
And so they're going to guard against that.
I think if you look at all of the money that society loses,
you know when you buy government debt protection and government regulation,
more money is lost to the cost of regulation.
Right.
Then would be lost through fraud or unscrupulous actors that,
you know,
that might steal somebody's money.
Well yeah,
but that money's not coming directly from victims.
The idea being that,
you know,
if,
if you're spending all this money on regulation,
that,
that money is not coming,
but you know,
the amount of money that you would lose if they weren't regulated with directly
affected.
Well,
it comes from every but like look at my industry,
my,
my.
I mainly make my money in the investment business.
I have a brokerage firm and an asset advisor company and so I advise people on
how to invest their money.
Now I have to spend a ton of money,
a fortune complying with regulation.
There's so much regulation in,
in my industry and it costs me.
I mean it's,
you know,
it,
it.
I don't know exactly what it is over a million dollars a year.
Much more that I have to spend a to stay in business and of course I have to
pass on those costs to my clients and of course be cost.
The costs are so big.
There's not a lot of comp,
you know,
there's,
there's less competition than there would be if the government didn't create all
these barriers to entry because if you want to compete with me,
you just can't do it.
You've got to have enough money to set up the compliance apparatus that the
government requires,
so there's a lot less competition in my industry.
And so I think that investors suffer because they don't have as much choices and
everybody has to pay higher prices for their services because the government
requires us to spend all this money supposedly to protect my customers,
but the government doesn't really give a damn about my customers.
I do.
I'm the one that suffers if my customers are mad at me because they take their
business someplace else,
right?
I,
I need happy customers,
so I am going to do what's right for my customers regardless of what the
government says.
Now there are some people out there that are gonna steal.
There are,
there's going to be criminals in every industry.
There's going to be some guy that's gonna,
you know,
fraudulent the pedal,
penny stocks or something that's going to happen,
but the problem is that's happening now even with all the government.
Look at Bernie madoff.
I mean you have all this stuff going on on top of it,
but if we didn't have any of this regulation,
if we have a free market,
yes,
there will still be some fools that would lose money,
but you know,
the losses would pale in comparison to how much everybody is losing now because
of the cost of government and at least the people who lose money.
We'd have to accept responsibility for their own bad decisions.
Why do my clients have to spend all this extra money?
Because somebody else is foolish with their money because now if you're
responsible,
you get punished.
Well,
this rant started when I was asking you about the BP spill,
the the idea that the government should possibly regularly that you don't.
You feel that the market should regulate in situations like that where they
should be responsible and be sued and that the government shouldn't step in and
force it because it seems like when you're dealing with something like bp,
you've got this massive corporation that has untold billions of dollars that
they can funnel and move and adjust and spend two to combat anything that would
cost them money.
But you know,
one of the ironies of the whole situation is why are we drilling in such deep
water in the first place?
And it has to do with government environmental regulation that made it very
expensive to drill in shallower water.
That would be,
you know,
less of an environmental threat.
It would be a lot easier.
But the government,
you know,
with all that regulation actually helped bring that situation about.
And also with
cut costs on the,
the way the well was construct.
But I also also,
what happened is the government came in and the government cap liability,
which was a mistake.
The government basically told,
um,
companies that your liability is capped at a certain amount.
And that was the government,
not the free market.
And so because there was a liability cap imposed by government corporations were
riskier,
so they would've been.
And then of course then bp said,
okay,
we're,
you know,
we're going to pay even beyond the,
beyond these camps,
but a lot of this was a byproduct of other government regulation and moral
hazard that resulted in,
in,
in drilling,
in deep water when we should've been drilling in shallower water,
we should be developing,
you know,
what if we were developing more up in Alaska,
but you know,
the government will let you do that.
And so the people of Alaska don't want it either.
No,
actually unchecked wilderness.
So I think that people of Alaska do.
No,
I think it's.
I think I talked about all the time I've been to Alaska.
You when you'd talk to the average person in Alaska about drilling and there's
some people there that want jobs that might say yes,
but most people don't have a vested interest in that.
They don't want any drilling up there.
And that place alone,
it's beautiful.
Well,
I mean it's also pretty big but not big,
but they don't want to fuck any of it up because if you start fucking up one
part,
why not fuck up other parts?
Why not before you know you're going to look out and you can see mountains with
oil wells,
so you're gonna see a lot of nonsense.
You're to see poisoning of the water.
You're going to see all that.
It's the last frontier.
There's,
I,
I see what you're saying when it comes to this idea of a government regulation
and BP,
but I don't see them spending money to,
to,
to fix it.
No,
no,
that's good.
You know how much,
you know,
how much money bp last,
uh,
you just see what happened to the value of their shares,
how much money they've had to spend a in litigation and claims
not enough,
but I don't know if they've done an unbelievable job fucking up the ocean.
They've killed massive amounts of wildlife.
I mean they should give everything they have ever made ever.
And then some,
but then they're not done is an unbelievable disservice to the planet itself.
Well,
you know,
a lot of people want to vilify.
Okay.
The big bad oil companies,
big oil companies,
they,
they cut corners and that's why it happened in the first place.
But okay,
so let's say we didn't have any oil companies.
I guess they're bad,
right?
So let's not say that that's a general blanket generalization,
but let's say we have an oil company that's like bp that cuts corners precisely
to save money and in doing so,
they cause a massive,
massive environmental damage that I believe personally you can't put a dollar
value on.
What they've done is enormous.
They've ruined a part of the earth.
Yeah,
but they obviously didn't do it intentionally.
So if you look at the data and you know what they didn't do intentionally,
they made money and in doing that intentionally and making money,
they made sure that they made as much money as possible in the shortest amount
of time as possible,
which led them to cut corners in the construction of the well,
which makes them ultimately responsible 100 percent for the damage.
And the damage is bad.
What they don't deserve.
What if we.
What if we
punished bp to the point,
let's say we destroy them,
we wiped him out,
wiped out their shareholders.
The company is bankrupt and they're no longer in the oil drilling business.
In addition,
we,
we increased the risks so much that nobody wants to listen.
We give them a new job.
The new job is clean the ocean.
That's my new job.
New Industry.
Meanwhile,
how?
I mean I'm in southern California,
right?
If,
if,
if we put the oil companies out of,
we're not completing them all
at it,
but believe me,
there's,
there's several oil companies,
but no one is responsible,
but something horrible.
What if bp went away and if we raise the risks of drilling for oil,
if we told companies,
look,
you know,
you screw up and you're gone,
right?
You're totally wiped out.
And so now insurance and liability insurance goes up and let's say so now
gasoline has to be,
I don't know,
$20 a gallon,
$3 account.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
No,
no,
no.
One.
One company going down is not going to.
No,
no,
no.
It's not $20.
It's not one company I'm talking about.
You're raising the cost throughout the entire.
You're going to have less people exploring for oil,
less people,
less money going,
you know.
In fact,
right now,
if you look at some of the oil companies,
they're barely even making money at a $100 oil.
I mean,
I,
I got bad news from and oil prices are going a lot higher anyway.
They're already going a lot higher.
So people in southern California have got to get ready for $10 a gallon.
Gasoline or hire someone listened to this conversation,
listen to you saying this and say,
well,
this guy does.
He thinks that banks should fail,
but oil companies shouldn't.
No,
no.
I think the free market should,
should,
should be allowed to,
uh,
to operate.
And so,
and,
and how do you assess liability and something like bp because bp,
I think that there's not enough money in the world will make up for what they've
done.
Look,
oh well,
a lot of people that are filing claims against BP,
they don't have it.
They didn't even ask.
They just all kinds of false or fraudulent claims are coming in by the damage.
I'm sure there was a few,
but there's maybe a few of those,
but you can't.
You can't doubt that there a lot of people affected by that.
The fisherman,
but people that work there,
but how about the actual impact on the earth itself,
but shouldn't they be responsible for that?
They are responsible,
but you can't overlook how are people's lives improved by the fact that we have
oil by the fact that we can drive cars around now if you want to invent oil and
BP,
but vent cars,
they didn't invent it,
but they're out there producing the oil well,
but because of that,
they should be able to do such a colossal fuck up and then they'll do.
Business members will make billions of dollars.
The government shouldn't have removed the liability restrictions.
That said that,
how much you can sue if you have real damages.
I want real market forces,
so you think that the market forces would have influenced them to spend more
money in the construction of the well not cut corners in order to reach it.
In fact,
they might not have even been drilling there.
I mean,
if it was a free market energy,
but they might've been trill drilling in areas,
uh,
that were generally safer,
but the government will let people would vote against that.
If given the opportunity.
Do you want to have a giant oil rig 50,
you know,
100 yards off shore where you could see it.
Most people are gonna say no.
Most people going to think that if there is a mistake,
which there are quite often.
I mean,
it's not all the time,
but we can think of several in our lifetimes.
We know about big oil disasters where Exxon val ds or whether it's this,
this,
uh,
this most recent one,
those happen.
People don't want that risk.
Yeah.
But I mean people also don't want extremely expensive gasoline,
so there's always a tradeoff.
But the big risks that we face,
I mean,
you could talk about an oil spill.
the,
the economic catastrophe that the government is in the process of is going
to have such a profound impact across this economy that these,
these,
these things,
while they're bad,
you know,
in our tiny compared to what's coming compared to the economic,
you,
this is California,
so we're gonna get a 10 plus on the Richter scale and the things that we're
talking about really don't even register can on it at all compared to what we're
going to go through in the United States.
I cost of government.
You can look at,
hey,
we think we want government to protect us from this,
but meanwhile you've got this huge,
enormous government that is creating a massive catastrophe that's coming and,
and,
and then we were probably going to end up with a lot more pollution when we're a
poor nation.
We can't even afford,
uh,
to,
to do the things that would keep the environment clean.
Or we're going to be chopping wood to stay warm and there'll be no pollution.
Will go completely cave man.
Well,
go with the other way.
And I trading metals that we find on the street.
Well,
look,
you probably initially there'll probably be some cleaner air here in southern
California and no one can afford to drive that.
See that?
That's the next crisis.
That's good.
Come is going to kill the dollar.
And then prices are gonna go way up.
And you know,
they,
you know,
they made,
ended up with,
uh,
with,
you know,
uh,
shortages because they might have price controls.
I think there's going to be big power blackouts because when energy costs really
sore,
because when the dollar tanks,
right,
even though we're producing a lot of oil in theU ,
s right now,
none of it's going to be consumed here.
It's all going to be shipped over to Asia because their currencies are going to
be stronger.
You know,
you imagine you've got all these people in China,
they're working hard,
they're in factories are producing,
they're saving,
uh,
but they're,
they're,
they're sacrificing to prop up our economy because a lot of the stuff that they
produce get shipped over here.
Well,
when the dollar collapses,
they're not going to shift stuff any over over here anymore.
They're gonna,
they're gonna make it and then they're going to take it home.
They're going to consume this stuff and you have a lot of Chinese now that are
riding around on bicycles.
Well,
you know,
when the dollar collapses,
they're not going to ride bicycles anymore.
They're going to drive cars and they're going to use a lot of gasoline.
Americans are going to be riding around on bicycles.
I still don't see how that relates to protecting environments from corporations
that pose massive.
No,
no.
My point is that the greatest threat to America is not corporations.
It's the government.
And,
and you know the interesting thing when you have a lot of people that are afraid
of corporations and these big corporations are bad.
It's like you know,
well,
but what could a corporation in general do to you if they can make a product and
they can hope that you buy it,
but it's your decision you choose and the way a corporation or which is just a
business,
right?
It's just the ownership structure is a corporation.
And the corporation run by people just like everybody else.
But if a corporation wants you to buy their product,
they have to give you a good deal.
They got to give you a better price than somebody else.
They got to give you a higher quality.
They have to win your business and you only buy their products or consume their
services if,
if,
if it's to your advantage to do so.
So it's all voluntary cooperation,
both sides benefit or nobody would trade.
So.
But if you look at government,
it's very different.
It's not,
we don't have a voluntary relationship with the government.
The government is forced.
The government says you have to do this or we're putting you in jail.
You have,
I'm going to force you to do this.
Um,
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna require you to do that.
You have to pay this tax.
And if you don't do it,
we put you in jail.
So government has real power.
Corporations have no power.
The government has all the power.
So we should fear government
have money though.
If corporates and save money and there is a government,
the corporations can influence the government.
It's always been the case.
It always will.
It hasn't always been the case,
but you're right,
to the extent that if we allow corporations to buy government influence that
corporations shouldn't be able to donate to political parties about might be a
potluck,
good reform because let individuals do it,
but you know,
but if we allow corporations right,
to,
uh,
to buy influence,
then that,
that's bad.
But the problem isn't that the corporations are buying it.
The problem is that we allow the government to sell it or to peddle associated.
If we were to go back to the constitution,
yeah,
but if we forced the government to obey the law,
then there is no influence to sell.
If,
if all we get from government is freedom,
right?
And Liberty,
which means we have laws that protect private property,
but we don't create special privileges for some people,
then there's no power to lobby,
to lobby for.
But right now we allow our politicians to sell power to the highest bidder.
That's not the Ford of the bitters.
The fault of the bitters because if I'm a business and I don't try to get a
favor from government,
what if my competition gets a favor and,
and then uses government power to squash me so everybody is forced to bid for
that power.
But the problem is government.
We have to take the power away from government and then there's no more lobbying
because there's nothing to lobby for.
Right?
But okay.
So how about a situation where like in the movie,
inside job we have these economics professors that they set these standards and
give advice and then they wind up getting jobs with banks.
You clearly need economic advisors though.
If I do,
don't the government in my.
I'm a senator and my background is in real estate sales or what have you.
Well,
let's say he's a businessman.
He sells computers and then he gets into politics.
What?
What do you really know about economics?
You have to have a degree in economics to trillium.
No,
I think if you have a degree in economics,
then you've probably lost you.
You probably know more about economics before you get your degree then after,
but you know,
you say you need economic advisors,
so we have a council of economic advisors for the president,
but that we didn't even have that before the Second World War.
There were no economic advisors advising the president,
but America became the wealthiest country the world had ever known.
I mean America in 1945,
right?
There is no comparison to America today.
I mean,
it was.
It was.
It was a completely different planet.
I mean,
being American was something totally different than what it means now.
There was no other country where the standard of living was even anywhere close
to what we enjoyed,
but we built that.
We built the wealthiest,
this wealthiest society in the history of the world,
way wealthier than
we are today in,
you know,
in relative terms,
without any economic advisors and all.
I mean,
we should fire everybody in Washington who was economic advisor and the title
that we don't need an economic advisors.
The best economy is a free economy.
It doesn't need micromanaged,
don't you?
If you,
if you want to be a socialist and you want to try to micromanage and centrally
planned the economy,
then you need advisors,
but if you believe in capitalism,
there is no advice,
just let the market function and then you're going to have the most efficient
outcome.
You're going to have the most efficient allocation of resources you're going to
have.
The higher standard of living for your people is when the government comes in
and tries to substitute individual judgments for the free market.
That's when you create problems,
but it wasn't the whole situation after World War II based on the fact that most
of the planet had been at war.
The economic situation in Europe was terrible because they had massive amounts
of destruction,
massive loss of lives.
Of course,
Japan had just surrendered to the United States.
China was a communist country.
There was so much even about the world and the job to say how great America was
is to compare it to what?
No.
Then go before the war.
Look at 19,
20.
I mean,
if you look at the rate of economic growth in the United States in the 19th
century,
take take the end of the civil war to the beginning of the first world war,
so forget about all the destruction.
Europe.
You look at 18,
65 to 1913.
You look at the change in wealth.
There was a.
There was nothing like America.
I mean,
why do you think all the immigrants were pouring into America from Europe?
It wasn't because they wanted to get on welfare because we had no welfare.
They wanted freedom.
We had something that the world didn't have.
You can come to America and do what you wanted.
There was no income tax.
There was no social security tax.
You can start a business.
You know,
there was no labor law.
You can.
Anybody can get a job.
Anybody can hire somebody,
but it can fire somebody.
You didn't have the government looking over your shoulder and we created massive
amounts of wealth,
not just for,
you know,
the rockefellers and the carnegies and you know,
the vanderbilts,
but for average people to standard of living rose rapidly.
Poor people from all over the world came to America,
uh,
you know,
to,
uh,
to pursue whatever they couldn't pursue in their own countries because they
didn't have the freedom,
but it was also a new territory.
It was a completely new uncharted land that had just started to set up cities
within the last hundred years.
People had heard about all the jobs that were available.
It was just a new why.
But why were those jobs there?
It was because we were free to create them.
And in their own countries they didn't have that level of freedom.
That was it.
It was capitalism on a scale that was never before.
Tried and,
and,
and this is where it's succeeded.
And we created that level of wealth without planners,
with,
without economic advisors,
without these taxes,
without these regulations.
And you know,
even though we had,
you know,
a lot of very,
very wealthy people,
how do they get wealthy?
They got wealthy by satisfying the demands and the needs of,
of,
of the masses of average people.
And you know,
and,
and everybody got wealthy together today.
What do we have now?
How do people get removed now?
Everybody didn't get wealthy together.
There was a lot of people that were poor as fuck back then as well as today.
No,
no,
no.
There's always going to be.
No,
no,
no.
There were people that were poor relative to people who were rich.
But if you take the typical person in 18,
65,
right.
He,
you know,
he lived on a farm.
He typical person to live on a farm.
We did.
They were both farmers telling them where people are going to New York to
Boston.
Oh No.
There were some people we were in a percentage of people lived in,
look,
look it up.
I don't know the exact person,
but people.
But even if they lived in New York,
okay,
okay.
They didn't have any electricity,
right?
They,
they,
they didn't have indoor plumbing,
have gangs of New York style,
but they didn't have air conditioning.
They lived,
you know,
but by,
by 1913 right now you had a lot of people living in cities,
but they had indoor plumbing.
They had electric lights.
They had to telephone.
Uh,
they,
they had,
uh,
you know,
all kinds of gadgets that made their lives better.
That didn't exist.
Uh,
in 18,
65.
I mean everybody's life got better,
but he got a symptom of just technological innovation and the constant
improvement of,
of devices and things that we've always gone through.
No,
we didn't always go through it.
I mean,
things have always gone through that.
If you go back for thousands of years,
we didn't have that kind of progress.
I mean,
if you will,
because it's exponential,
but if you were,
but it was the freedom that we had and that enabled us to do it.
I mean,
it wasn't an accident,
sort of a lot of things that was created in Europe.
There was a lot of things that were created in China.
They developed over the world.
If you look at where America was,
you know,
going into the first world war and you look at like all the cars and all the,
the 90 percent of everything was here.
I mean,
we made everything.
We consumed everything.
We had our standard of living unparalleled.
I mean,
poor people in America were,
you know,
were wealthy in other countries.
That's where the whole expression ugly American came from and somebody in
American would go to Europe,
uh,
and they were just a school teacher or a plumber and they got there and they
thought they were king because everything was so cheap compared to things.
Here we have so much that,
that people didn't know the term ugly American came from us being assholes
because we
didn't want to speak the language.
We would go over there.
No,
you speak English.
We went to France.
It,
the attitude that we had when we got there of superiority and how,
which we were and how everybody didn't have any of the things that we had.
That was really where it came from.
Maybe we'll listen to.
I'm guessing you're guessing as well.
Neither one of us were in Europe in the fifties,
so we don't really know where that term actually came up,
but that's how,
that's how it ordinate require assholes.
I think there's a big percentage of us that are shitheads and we go to other
countries.
I've seen it.
I've seen people that are American,
they're another countries act stupid,
but not so much anymore.
I mean,
we'd go to other countries and now we have complained about how expensive
everything is.
We don't brag about how cheap it is because those days are.
Those days are gone and of course you know,
back then all the products were made in America and we exported all those
products.
I think that because we had cheap wait labor,
we had the highest wages in the world.
There's a lot going on there.
I certainly think that creativity and innovation help or it helps it to be free,
to have freedom certainly is gonna enhance the ability to create and
an ability to put out new inventions and new things that are gonna make life
easier.
No,
no,
no question about it,
but the idea that that has to be all completely unregulated by the government
makes me very nervous and I know the word that I don't trust the government
either.
I don't know.
I don't like the word the government,
but I think an unregulated industry that can pollute like bp has is incredibly
dangerous.
But you've got regulation though.
I mean the government takes it down.
Like here,
if you want to cut hair,
do you want to be a barber?
You got to get licensed.
You got to take exams,
right?
I mean why does it.
You don't want some crazy ass hole.
Doesn't know how to use a pair of scissors.
We'll just open up a shop.
And you're the first guy who works on pretty much.
Yeah,
but.
So you get a bad haircut.
You don't go back.
I mean,
what's the worst thing that can happen?
Okay.
In haircuts.
Yes.
How about fixing a car?
But even book,
even the car tire could come,
fly down the highway and die.
Well,
so you know,
so if there's a mechanic,
right,
that,
that get it has a,
you know,
he doesn't know how to put out a tire and you know,
a couple of people have an accident.
He's out of business.
No one's going to go out of business.
People are going to die.
I think money is not as important as making sure this guy,
no set of fixed cars,
but if family say,
but if you invest money in a business,
right,
the most important thing you have is your reputation,
your brand,
your customer,
goodwill.
The business owner is going to make sure,
right?
That he's got,
you know,
mechanics that know what they're doing.
He's going to not,
they're going to take a chance and maybe they'll go out of business,
but they might fuck up.
Look,
people aren't rational.
You're here idea that everyone who starts a business is going to know exactly
what they're doing because they have to.
The ones that don't posture,
the ones that don't know what they're doing will go under,
but yeah,
it shouldn't.
You stop that.
If it's a case of something being safe.
No,
someone's a doctor.
Dentist.
If someone's working on your health or working on your car or working on your
house,
look,
they put your,
your pipes in incorrectly and your fucking house catches on fire.
You don't think you should have to be certified by at least,
but hold on a second,
but at least some sort of a standard in their industry or industry agrees upon
standard.
Why does it have to come from government doesn't make what they used to have
before government is it.
You would join a society,
right?
A voluntary society which would give you like a good housekeeping seal of
approval.
So you would say,
Hey,
I'm a mechanic and look,
I'm a member of this organization and they come and they periodically examined
my business and they certified that I have all the safety.
I mean the free market will find solutions so that companies can say,
you know,
yes,
like a better business bureau kind of seal of approval,
but when the government does it,
I think it's not nearly as effective and I think it does create a moral hazard.
People,
you know,
have a lot of corruption there.
But even look,
it goes to everything.
You need licenses to arrange flowers.
So if you want to get a job as a floral arranger,
you got to get a government licensed.
I mean,
so what if the guy doesn't arrange the flowers,
right?
What's the big deal?
But you know what happens?
You have who,
who suffers from all these occupational licensing laws and regulations.
It's poor people.
It's inner city people that never can get jobs.
They never can improve their skills.
They're permanently locked out of a profession or an occupation.
Meanwhile,
the consumer has fewer choices and has to pay higher prices.
We all suffer from this.
You know,
you can say,
well,
you know,
maybe a few people that wouldn't have got bad haircuts,
don't.
Alright,
well let that happen.
I'd rather have that than everybody have to pay more for a haircut.
The haircut example,
yes,
I'm with you.
It's not.
It's a frivolous thing.
It's not that big a deal.
The real issue I have is with things like construction or things like electrical
things that involves safety and I think you and I are both not in favor of the
government regulating these things because I don't necessarily think they're
going to do the best job.
The industry itself should regulate.
If the industry could prove some sort of a very efficient,
very competent and very educated regulatory system,
then the government should just step down and say,
look,
we're not going to do this anymore.
We're going to let the hair cutters,
association of America,
most people,
most of these organizations started out in the private sector.
But the reason they got government involved is they wanted protection from
competition.
And so whenever you like and why and what and how so?
Well,
because let's,
let's assume that we're,
you know,
we know we were basket weavers,
right?
And we,
you know,
we all weave baskets and be the best way.
Let's say we have a society where you say,
look,
if you're,
if you pay your dues,
you know,
we'll,
we'll give you a certified member of basket weavers of America.
And if anybody sees that sign on your shop,
they know that you really know how to weave a basket.
You went through our vigorous training program.
You took a course,
you know we have,
but now,
but once you have this group,
they say,
you know what?
If we could simply require everybody to be a member of our group and make it
illegal for them to sell any baskets.
If they're not a member of our group,
then we can charge a lot more money if we can because we won't have competition.
So they go to Washington,
they say,
hey,
why don't you require anybody who weaves baskets to join our organization and
forced them into it?
Right.
That's what I'm in.
In the brokerage industry.
I'm only allowed to be a stockbroker because I'm a member of Finra right now.
I don't want to be a member of Finra.
I'd rather just be a stockbroker and not be a member of member,
but that's it.
I can't.
It's the government made it illegal,
so in order for me to be a stockbroker,
I have to be in this organization and I have to spend millions of dollars a year
to comply with all these ridiculous rules and regulations,
but the net effect of it is that there's a lot fewer brokers than there would be
if we didn't have finra and I.
I know now if Finra was voluntary,
if it was private,
then I could just say,
hey,
I'm a broker and I'm not a member of Finra.
So caveat emptor,
you know,
just,
I would much rather have that than have to be,
but you know,
all these organizations,
they always want it.
They always want the government to,
uh,
prevent,
you know,
forced people to join so that they can charge more money and have less
competition.
But I think also the idea is that the government is going to be the one that's
impartial.
The government's going to be standing outside looking at this industry having no
vested interest in you profiting over you or you over you and say,
Hey,
these are the rules and this is how we can make this fair and ethical.
No,
the governments,
the idea that most people have about the but they do have a vested interest
because now this organization,
right,
that got the government to force everybody to join it.
Now they're going to give donations to the government to continue to help
support those.
Stopped for you and I when we became a week.
But we said that that's not legal anymore,
but we haven't stopped that,
so it's still going on.
So that did,
let's say,
part of the problem,
if we step in and stop that no one is allowed to give any more money to the
government.
No campaigns,
no nothing.
That,
that's actually not even going to stop it.
What has to stop it is you have to,
you have to take away the government's power to do all these things because
they're going to,
as long as I have the power,
uh,
there's going to be.
People will get around those requirements and there'll be ways to do it.
You have to limit the power of government,
which is what we did so successfully for our first hundred,
150 years as a republic.
We were very successful at limiting the power of government.
And that's why we achieved so much.
The problem is,
you know,
we lost that advantage.
The government,
you know,
was chained up by the constitution.
Uh,
but it's,
it freed itself from those chains.
And,
and so now it does whatever it wants and,
and we're suffering as a result because we've lost a lot of freedom and by
losing the freedom we lost all the opportunity and economic growth that went
along with it.
Yeah,
but someone has got to keep these corrupt evil fucks that have billions of
dollars from running a muck at this situation.
Well,
who's going to run right now?
Who's going to run a muck?
What?
How did this financial crisis happened?
And it happened from people running them out,
but they couldn't have run a muck at the government wasn't.
It wasn't guaranteeing their,
their businesses,
their loans,
their portfolios,
but you think that they acted knowing that they could fail and if they did fail,
the government bailed them out.
No.
Or you reacted in Hubris thinking they wouldn't fail.
They're going to pull this off.
They've been pulling this off.
Do you think all these people knew that the edge was coming and they just kept
running?
Look,
government with some didn't.
It was a little bit of both,
but if the government wasn't there,
right?
Saying I'll catch you if you fall,
then you're not going to get up on that high wire.
I you're going to be a lot more cautious with what you're doing or you agree
that you would be more cautious,
but I think that people are assholes and I think that people who have a lot of
money and a lot of Hubris and a lot of ego and it probably on pills,
they're going to do some wild,
wacky shit.
No,
they have and they always will in a free market.
They won't.
You know it getting rich and a free market,
but they will.
They will.
They may fail in doing so,
but they certainly will know when.
See people when,
when you.
When you earn a lot of money,
the most important thing is not to lose it,
right?
You want to protect what you were in and so people are going to act to preserve
what they have.
There's fear and greed that that are,
that are,
that are that are there.
Yes,
people want more,
but they don't want to give up what they have.
The government comes in and says,
don't worry,
be a take all the risks you want.
We got you covered.
We've got your back.
That's what was going on in Wall Street with all this cheap money.
They make it a lot less expensive for everybody to lever up and go out and
borrow and speculate and you know all this wealth that is being generated for a
small number of people,
you know,
this is not the way it used to be when you would get rich by helping everybody,
by providing people with a goods and services and creating jobs.
That's how people got rich 100 years ago.
That's not how they're getting rich now.
They're,
they're getting rich off the government.
They're getting rich by.
They get the money first.
They get the money,
cheapest.
They get to borrow money at practically nothing and speculate with it.
They create no
real wealth for society,
uh,
but they're getting rich on their own.
But all of this is phony.
All this is going to end in complete disaster,
but it is not the market's fault.
It is not capitalism that has done this.
It's the government.
It's the central bank,
I think we both agree on government intervention,
but I think where we're disagreeing is on human nature and I think that people
are naturally greedy.
They,
they're,
they're naturally likely to do something illegal and try to get away with it.
Not sure they are.
If they can profit off of it or you know,
mom neither by why do you believe somebody else's?
Because there's murderers in the world,
in the world.
Look at the crime reports on the internet or read the news.
There's,
there's a million things that go on everyday that will prove to you that people
don't abide by the law when they,
when they don't have to do or they think they can get away with it.
Yeah.
Look,
there are bad people in the world.
I know they're,
I think they're in the minority.
I think the majority of people are good.
I think there are bad people.
Unfortunately,
a lot of them are in government,
uh,
and that,
and they have a lot of power there and bad people gravitate to govern.
Don't you think that that keeps people from doing some of these bad things?
Knowing that they're going to get in big trouble front.
No,
no,
no.
I mean most people,
right?
I don't steal because it's wrong.
I don't,
I don't not steal because I might go to jail.
Right.
I just morally know that I'm not going to take somebody that doesn't belong to
me.
Right.
And most of us are the same way that it's not,
it's not that we're,
you know,
and most people and most people who get rich are good,
hardworking,
honorable people.
Most the majority.
Is it even one out of 100 to 100,
which is one percent of people that are scumbags.
I don't know.
Fuck up and do a lot when you're dealing with 300 million.
No,
but didn't get a good free market economy.
The scumbags are only gonna go so far,
right?
Yeah.
They're going to ultimately get,
get weeded out.
Uh,
they're gonna.
They're,
they're,
you know,
you,
you don't build a great business,
lasting business.
Being a scumbag.
I mean,
you maybe you can succeed in the short run,
but eventually you're going to go away and that's the free market is going to
purge itself of the bad operators and yes,
some people are going to get ripped off.
I mean that's the nature of it.
But you know,
in a free market,
fewer people will get ripped off then in the type of government market we have
now.
But I am not afraid.
I'm not worried about a businessman and entrepreneur because I know that all of
my associations with him,
absent government or voluntary,
all he can do is try to offer me a good deal and I can turn it down.
But when they go to government and say,
we're going to force you to buy this product,
like,
here were the obamacare.
Okay,
you've got to buy insurance.
You know?
Well,
what I,
what have,
I don't need it.
What if I don't like it?
I mean,
I,
I want to be able to make a decision because in a free market,
if I buy something,
it's because I thought it was good for me.
Now,
maybe I'm wrong,
but at least I came to a decision that I thought something was in my interest,
but now the government says you have to do something whether you think it's in
your interest or not,
and that's and that's power and that's something that people should be afraid
of.
When the government can force you to do things that you don't want to do,
corporations can't do that unless they get the government involved to help them
and that's not the fault of the corporation.
It's the fault of the government or the people that allow the government to have
that power.
I feel you.
I see what you're saying and I agree with you.
For the most part.
I think the only problem that
I'm having with what you're saying is the idea that the government would
regulate environmental protection or that rather industry or business would
regulate environmental protection.
I don't think they would.
I think that if,
if they were in a situation where they're making billions of dollars and they
had some sort of a catastrophic oil spill or chemical spill or some sort of a
disaster,
they would cover it up just like it's been proven that's been done with
fracking.
I mean there's a real issue with fracking right now in America and if you've
watched any of the documentaries or read any of the articles that are written
about people's areas,
farms,
water supplies,
destroyed the oxygen level in the atmosphere changes.
Well,
you know,
I level,
I'm involved pretty heavy with fracking myself because we have a lot of wells
that we own.
I own myself and my own on behalf of my favorite cracker.
I guess.
I mean,
I'm in North Dakota.
I'm up in the bock and I started there about three years ago.
And look,
I mean,
I mean there's tremendous wealth that's been created up in,
up in,
up in that region in North Dakota.
And it's one of the bright spots of the US economy.
I mean,
fortunately the energy industry,
uh,
you know,
on,
domestically is doing something,
you know,
it's a pocket of strength and,
and,
you know,
and you know,
we're an island of strength and see a weakness.
I mean most of what's going on is bad,
but that's one of the things that we got going and we're going to need to
develop our,
our,
our energy resources even more effectively,
especially once the dollar cloud are the actual invite since,
you know,
then,
uh,
while I'm doing the actual environmental,
you're already environmental problems with fracking.
You know,
I,
I think it's more,
I think you have a lot of people on the left who,
you know,
they're really socialist but they don't want to come out and,
and just,
you know,
they were communists or whatever,
but they,
so they want to,
you know,
clothes,
everything in environmentalist language.
They,
what they really want to take away private property.
Uh,
but they,
they don't want to come out and say it.
So they close themselves.
Did everybody that doesn't want frackers to ruin the
drinking water?
They certainly have in many places.
They're not ruining.
They have water.
Why have these companies that have been fracking come in and shipped fresh water
to these people that have lost their drinking water where they can fucking light
it on fire now?
What's,
what's going on?
It's not happening in any circumstance whatsoever.
Go,
go.
I will go out and you laugh about that.
That seems like a goal to North Dakota,
you know?
I mean,
you know,
do I have to go to North Dakota to get an answer?
No,
but it's not this horrible thing.
You know,
I think safe places,
I think they overplay the what's going on and you know,
the,
the same thing.
They've been doing this with,
you know,
with various,
we got to save this species,
this subspecies subspecies.
We can't go here.
We can't get.
But a lot of it did,
did an environmental disaster happened in the Gulf?
Did millions and millions of gallons of oil gets built?
No.
I'm not saying please did it.
Yes.
There was an environmental concern that that could take place almost anywhere in
the country because the systems that we have in place are not foolproof and this
is a new thing
that is not just,
not just is it a new thing,
but most people are not even aware of it.
They start getting aware of it.
They start seeing things like people's water being able
to be lit on fire.
They start talking to people that have been forced out of their farms because
they're groundwater's polluted.
They're there,
they can smell it in the air.
This is some sick shit and now they're ruining parts of the country.
But the,
the accident with bp and it wasn't just bp was there's other companies involved.
Um,
but the accident there happened with all the regulation that we have.
But it did happen.
Right?
Right.
But we have regulation but the regulation preventatively,
but I'm saying more regularly,
I'm not saying more regulation,
I'm saying should you do it at all just because the fact that you can do it and
maybe make wealth out of it if you are causing massive environmental disaster.
No.
Should that be okay just because you're making money,
as I said,
if you want to have a tradeoff,
if you want to say no,
drilling offshore,
right,
because something bad might happen.
If you want to eliminate all that water,
that oil,
then be prepared to pay a lot more for gasoline and a lot and a lot more for
products that we consume that not only have gasoline,
but by the way right now,
and of course this is going to change,
but most of the stuff that we consume in America isn't made here.
It has to get shipped here on a,
on a,
on a big ship that comes across from China and it takes a lot of gasoline and
get it over here.
So every single thing that we buy in America,
you know,
there's a lot of energy that goes into getting it here.
And so if we're going to make energy much more expensive because we want to make
sure that we can have another environmental accident,
right?
Then we better be prepared to accept the lower standard of living that,
that comes with that.
But you see what you're doing here,
this problematic.
You are automatically leaning towards the profit side over the environment side.
This is what makes people really nervous about people that are really into the
market.
What your concern is is not about the earth itself,
the very place where your children are grow up.
That's not what you're concerned about.
You're not concerned about that you were concerned about the devastation to the
market by regulating these businesses and forcing them to raise the price of
gasoline and everyone's going to suffer because we didn't let everybody take
this fucking wacky chance and pump fluid into the ground and pull out oil or
what I'm not saying,
do you see that argument is a very callous because.
But I'm not saying that a business shouldn't be held responsible for the damages
it causes.
I'm not saying just responsible fracking is fucking dangerous.
Everybody that's fracking isn't,
uh,
isn't,
you know,
causing pollution for somebody else.
But a lot of people are well then,
but then that can be addressed on a case by case basis.
Mean those places are poisoned,
poison those.
Once those farms are ruined,
there's family farms that people can't have cattle graze in anymore because the
cattle are getting sick.
They can't grow food there.
The pull,
the big problem,
the biggest problems of farmers have is the government and it's like farm
program.
It's not fracking.
If you want to find out what the,
you know,
what's going on with our farms.
I mean go get rid of the Department of Agriculture will get rid of all
necessarily government programs.
Government allowed people the frackers to use.
They'll all that water and fracking.
I kick him millions of gallons of water.
Small farmers come on my radio show and they tell me about all the problems
that the government is created for them,
putting them out of business and,
and,
and the things that they're doing to regulate them out of existence.
Government is evil,
but that doesn't have anything to do with fracking.
The dangers,
the dangers of fracking are very real.
Well,
I think the dangers are way overblown and I think that maybe you've,
you,
you've read some things and you've got,
you know,
you've seen some of this stuff and I think it is distorting the reality of
fracking.
It is not,
uh,
as,
as dangerous as some people would like everybody to believe.
Right.
And
more significant to me than the RTU.
If there's an environmental disaster,
I think that's a big concern to me.
I don't think it's as big as.
So why,
why,
why would it be more of a concern for you?
I mean,
I,
you know,
because I'm,
I'm not invested,
I don't have invested interest in profit.
You've already said that you profited off of fracking,
but there's nothing wrong with that.
But I would tell you this,
if we were not producing all that energy that we're producing now out of North
Dakota,
I mean,
prices would be much already.
Well,
no,
I'm not saying I'm not saying to sky,
the sky's going to fall anyway because we got,
we got bigger problems than fracking,
but you know,
the fact that we have been able to generate more energy,
you know,
that's something that we've done.
That's been a net positive that's been helping us.
If we didn't have that,
things would be a lot worse.
I mean,
if you think the economy is bad right now,
it would be a lot worse if we weren't generating that for that energy.
If instead we had to borrow money to buy that,
you know,
from Saudi Arabia or wherever we're importing it,
it would be,
it would be even worse.
But you know,
there's nothing wrong when people.
A lot of times people have a bad view of profits,
I mean prophets or some kind of evil bad thing.
No,
no,
that's not what we're saying here.
Well,
we're talking about is environmental concern over profits and the you have this
profits over environmental concern when you keep going,
oh,
there's a few little things might happen here and there,
but look at how much money we're gonna save.
If we do this,
look at how much money is looking,
how much wealth,
Joe,
if you look around the world and you look at which countries have the most
pollution,
generally it's the countries that had the most government and the countries that
have less pollution,
will have less government.
I mean,
you know,
a,
a clean environment is a valuable asset that the market will preserve.
Am I saying that there should be no.
Regulation
is ruined.
It's ruined.
You're extracting money out of an area by.
Okay.
If you look at that area is ruined and polluted.
It's where you can look at some of the areas of Africa where,
you know,
where a lot of private money has come in and tried to create,
a wildlife reserves where there's now instead of hunting elephants now for their
ivory,
there's a lot of people now they're spending money,
uh,
preserving them because people,
you know,
they want to come in and take a safari there and they want to see them in there
and habitat.
So you have entrepreneurs seeing a profit in preserving an environment in a way
that they can profit from it.
If there wasn't a way to profit from it,
people wouldn't be explaining the money to do that.
Actually a really good example because you know how they really profit off of
elephants.
One of the big ways allowing hunters to go over there.
They have people spending money to kill these.
Well that's the idea
of preserving.
No,
no,
no.
The people that are trying to preserve them or trying to stop the poaching.
Poaching.
We were talking to regulating hunting.
They,
they,
they have regulated hunting expeditions for elephants.
Well,
I'd be like,
I,
you know,
I know there's some big game hunting and I'm sure that,
to the extent that there's hunting there,
you know,
I mean,
they're not hunting them to extinction.
I don't know what it costs to shoot an elephant hunter probably.
Especially if you're going to have the head mount that had taken back and was
just to pay to have.
It's a very expensive but they have to keep it alive.
But in order to be there to shoot it,
it has to exist.
You can't wipe out,
you can't wipe out the,
uh,
the,
the herd.
But could you imagine if that argument was used for people?
Well then we have to keep the population healthy by hunting them.
We have to do it not to shoot a few people every now and then.
That would be,
that would be an,
it costs a million dollars.
You'd be on here.
It's a million dollars in profit is generated.
If you shoot a person,
that's how much gas would cost if you didn't shoot that would take one person,
you shoot them and they got everybody else healthy and well fed.
We had a hunger games type scenario where we had to kill a couple of people
every year,
but everybody else live great.
I think that's got nothing to do with what I'm good at,
what my argument that you often offered left field,
but I'm not even the left guy.
The,
the,
the environment is not left.
It's not always left.
It to the extent the earth itself,
to the extent that you know,
we need regulation for externalities that result from pollution.
It can be done at a more local level than having
the funding where South Dakota going to get the money to pursue a gigantic oil
company that's ruining its environment.
There aren't,
well the northwest,
North Dakota where all the fracking is,
but let's say South Dakota comes up with a new fracking or where do you think
the federal government gets the money from the North Dakotans.
I mean the federal government doesn't have any money that's taken from us.
So why send it to Washington?
I mean,
you're out here in California.
Why does California have to send me to Washington and Beg for it back?
I mean let California deal with its own problems and keep the money here,
but when you're thinking about all the income tax and deals with it,
who's going to do with it?
If the government doesn't deal with it in South Dakota,
doesn't deal with it.
Who deals with the people who have to go up against the frackers and show up
with torches?
There's a government in South Dakota that government's going to deal with,
but if you're going to let a government do it,
why does it have to be the federal government,
Washington?
Why can't it be a local government so the government is okay with the federal
government's not.
Okay.
When it comes to regulating environmental protection,
the closer you are to the the what you're regulating,
the more efficient it's going to be the least corrupt it's going to be.
If you're going to regulate,
you want to regulate as close to the activity as possible.
You don't want to have it outsourced to Washington dc because it's going to cost
much more and it's going to be less effective,
but a lot of people want Washington to pay for it because somehow they think it
doesn't cost anything,
but it actually costs more when Washington pays for it.
Then when your local government pays for it,
but most of the stuff is going to be in the courts.
I'm not saying that a business should be able to dump pollution onto your.
You know your property.
You can sue them for that.
That's a tort.
That's wrong.
They have take care of it,
have to make sure that they don't know,
but that's sort of disingenuous because you know how incredibly difficult it is
for a farmer to sue a gigantic corporation.
They've ruined all their land.
The corporation has billions of dollars spent.
You know,
they won't.
The lawyer,
the lawyers,
the lawyers will take the case on a contingency.
If you've got a big plaintiff,
no problem.
People don't have a profit.
The problem that we have in this country with Laura's,
it's too easy to sue people.
I mean,
there's so much lawsuits here because you know,
uh,
if you sue somebody,
you basically can extort money out of the cost so much to defendant agree with
you that there are frivolous lawsuits.
There's lots of them.
And so it's not that people can't sue if they've been wrong.
We have too many people suing who haven't been wrong,
but it's because they're shaking down.
But it's crazy to pretend that corporations would automatically give people
money if they were wrong,
that they would like,
all someone has to do is get together a lawyer and sue them.
It'd be easy.
It's not going to be easy.
They're going to fight tooth and claw.
They're going to put it off as long as possible.
They're going to drag you through the mud.
They're going to drown you in legal fees.
That's what they do.
That's what they've done,
but they've got to pay those legal fees and pennies to them in comparison with
what they'd have to pay.
If they gave you millions dogs to the ruin your farm.
Well,
they could save and legal fees by just dragging the case out and using quality
lawyers that really know how to manipulate the system.
The idea that they would do it on their own because of the market,
is that I have a problem with that.
I don't know who should regulate it.
You seem to think that the state government will be qualified.
I see state governments as being woefully understaffed,
woefully underfunded.
California is fucking bankrupt,
so going after anybody
fornia is underfunded.
I mean,
look at all the revenue.
Look at all the income taxes that are paid in the state of California.
Look at all the property taxes that are sent up there to Sacramento.
I mean,
California is the problems in California,
not because the government doesn't have enough money.
It's a government has too much money,
there's too much garbage is too much tax.
It's just too much regulation.
There's too many people who work for government because they have to be
supported by everybody else.
I mean,
they don't produce anything.
most people who work for government,
not only don't they produce anything,
they get in the way of other people who would produce stuff,
but the government won't let them,
you know,
so we're all poor because we have to pay the salaries while these government
workers.
And now if you actually look at how much government workers make relative to
private sector workers,
you throw in all the benefits.
The average person working for government is making twice as much as the average
person working in the private sector.
Why do you think all the wealthiest counties in America are all surrounding
Washington in DC?
I mean,
they're sucking the life out of the rest of the country.
They're all,
yeah,
they're all getting rich lobbyists and politicians and the lawyers because
that's where all the power is.
That's where you know as well as Washington gets wealthier.
Everybody else gets poor because they don't make anything.
They don't produce anything.
They suck the blood out of everybody else.
Well,
I agree with you on that.
I mean we're.
We're in total agreement with where we seem to differ is on the idea of
environmental protection.
That's where we seem to.
You seem to think the market will take care of it.
I seem to think there's no fucking way the market would ever take care of it
unless you held a gun to their head.
You know what I mean?
I would be okay if they left all the environmental rules place that I
think shouldn't be there because this.
Which ones specifically are.
I mean,
do you know which ones do you have a problem with you don't think should be
there?
Well,
because I've heard you say that you think the EPA should have the environmental
code book in front of me.
I know.
I'm not sure as a scientist or someone has a vested interest in fracking and it
must be a few concerns.
Yeah.
I,
I just know that I think there's more laws on the books then,
then we should have certainly for the federal,
but I'm saying my point is even if I'd be fine leaving them all there because
the problem that we are creating from excess environmental regulation right is
small compared to all the other problems.
I mean,
like you'd have to reset rubber regulation.
You always talking about what about drugs,
right?
What about,
oh,
the government needs to uh,
you know,
make sure that the drugs are safe.
But I,
I'm,
I'm pretty sure that more people die because drugs that might've helped them are
kept off the market.
Then people who die because a drug,
you know,
killed,
you know.
And I think the reason that pharmaceuticals and drugs are so expensive in
America is because it's so expensive to get something approved by the FDA.
I think we had a much better and much healthier system before the FDA existed.
And at least initially the FDA only made you prove that your drugs weren't
harmful.
Now you have to prove that they're not harmful and that they work right,
that they're efficacious.
And that is extremely expensive.
Well,
how would you,
how could you possibly sell something if you don't prove it's not dangerous?
No,
no,
let's that.
Well,
because the doctor has to prescribe it.
So let's say I'm a medical doctor,
right?
And let's say I'm your doctor and you trust me.
And I actually looked at a drug and I,
I'm convinced based on my examination,
I looked at their own studies.
I'm convinced it's a good drug and I think it's going to help you.
Right?
But,
but companies,
Dr. Studies all the time like who's this town?
But why?
But why do you trust the FDA?
Why do you trust them?
Do we need to trust someone?
But who would you rather trust?
A doctor that you know or some bureaucrat you've never met who doesn't even know
who you are.
I don't think my doctor has enough time to review all of the medication in the
world and all the studies that have been done,
all the different classes have been done on different types of people.
Okay.
Let's forget about the harm part because that's a little bit.
Maybe no,
but advocacy is important,
but the hard part is probably the most.
The efficacy as the more expensive.
Okay.
But the advocacy should also be in place for things like cancer drugs and
dealing with things like devastate the immune system and may or may not be,
but if it doesn't harm you,
okay.
If they were profit,
if it can harm you,
then why can't the garment lit it on the market?
Why is it bullshit?
Because I let people decide if it's bullshit.
Let doctors decide.
Let patients decide what if there's a drug that would save me?
Right,
but the government says,
no,
we want to keep testing it.
We know it can't hurt you,
but we want to just do another three years of testing.
Meanwhile,
I die while I'm waiting for that drug to come.
Why can't I say,
look,
I don't care about the test,
I just want to drug,
and the governor says you can't.
You have to wait,
and I know that there are a lot of drugs that work that they don't let on the
market.
You know,
and you're talking about what about what if I'm a big pharmaceutical company and
I have a lot of money and some small company that comes out with a new pill
that's better than mine that has no side effects.
I don't want it on the market.
What do I do?
I give money to do my politician in my hip pocket.
Can I say you killed that drug because that's better than my drug.
It has less side effects and I don't want the competition so they keep it up,
but that really has nothing to do with the Fba solved in these conspiracies.
I don't know,
but a politician are on these committees can squash these structures.
You don't think they do that.
You don't think you,
you.
You talked about how you're saying that how evil companies are when they.
When they get in bed,
you don't think some people are evil,
right,
but wouldn't some of those evil people you know,
try to have their friends in government squash and competitor's product?
It's very possible.
That would be a crime.
Yeah,
but they do it anyway.
You don't think politicians commit crimes,
but don't you think that that would always take place?
Those kinds of crimes?
It takes.
Yes,
because of the FDA,
so you think that if there was no regulatory commissions or no governing bodies
when it comes to drugs,
that what we will do is just put it all on the market and we would all figure
out what was effective.
What was that look at a minimum.
Just say,
show that it doesn't hurt you,
but the minute you have to prove that it works,
it's so easy for them to say,
oh,
the proof isn't conclusive.
We're not going to prove you.
It's too subjective because showing that it doesn't harm you.
Okay?
You can show that yes,
people took this drug,
may didn't get sick.
They didn't get harmed.
When there's drugs out there that actually do work and you're taking a drug that
doesn't work because the company lied and then attempts to years to find out
because it's a new product.
Now you're assuming that your doctor's an idiot who prescribed it to you.
How would the doctor know if he prescribed phen phen or via all these different
drugs that have been pulled off the market medical school after they have been
prescribed by people who went to medical school,
but if your doctor doesn't know who went to medical school and is a doctor,
how does some bureaucrat and the FDA know who maybe didn't go to medical school
and isn't competent enough to be a doctor?
That's why these companies to show a tremendous amount of work showing the
efficacy and safety of their product.
That's what the FDA's job is.
It might not be that good at it.
It might cost a lot of money,
but the idea behind it is that you have these stringent ex extremely while.
Meanwhile,
Joe,
it takes you a lot more time to develop a drug and it takes a lot more money.
And because of that,
you know,
two companies can only,
you have some illnesses,
are some diseases that only affect a small number of people.
And so because it's so expensive,
nobody can do it.
So what,
what,
what did drug companies need to do?
They come up with cures for baldness,
uh,
because that they can mass market or they want to,
you know,
deal with erectile dysfunction,
but if you've got a,
you know,
a disease that might kill you,
but it's only affecting a small percent of the population.
Nobody can afford to spend the R and D on it.
It's to the government makes it so expensive for companies to do this.
Why not just get out of the way?
Why not trust human beings and just don't assume that everybody else is an idiot
and let people make decisions for themselves.
But I know,
look,
I mean,
I can smell the pot when I walk in here,
right?
I mean,
how dare you,
right?
So I mean,
look,
I want,
I want marijuana to be legalized,
I mean so because I trust people to make decisions.
Well you don't want that because if people are going to get high,
they're gonna not let you frack what are they doing?
But I'm sure you agree with me,
right,
that marijuana should be legal to smoke marijuana.
What certainly should be illegal to do?
Almost everything because everything that doesn't hurt people,
but there's a difference between different.
In what way?
Well,
you trust people to smoke pot responsibly or to drink or if you're smoking pot,
you're not fracking.
They're two different things.
Case scenario,
you might get you guys,
hi,
because you're in the room,
you get might get some secondhand pot.
You know the difference between that and the environmental protection.
This is a huge difference between that and regular regulating environmental
disasters or.
No,
I'm just very consistent in,
in my view of the world,
right?
I just,
I believe that we're all about money and Martin.
No,
no.
I'm about individual liberty and freedom.
You're also about the market.
None of that.
But that's because that's an expression of free people coming together in a free
market.
It's individuals making exchanges that are mutually beneficial to both parties.
That's what freedom is all about.
The minute you involve government,
the minute you have laws and regulations,
what that does is diminish our freedom because the government tells us what we
can't do,
right?
If the government doesn't say we can,
we can't do it,
then we can do it.
And so that's why government laws should all about,
should be about protecting private property and life and liberty that,
look,
I can do whatever I want as long as I don't infringe upon you,
right?
I can't,
I,
you know,
I have a right to pursue my own happiness.
But I can't steal from you to do it.
I can't,
I can't injure you.
And that's where,
yes,
I can't pollute your air.
I can't pollute your water.
I agree with you there.
But as long as I'm not harming you,
if you're polluting my water.
And I said I can't do that.
But you do if you're fracking.
But your response to that
and you can get money.
Yes,
you can,
but do you see that that is not a,
that's not an answer,
but people don't want to get sued and mean people that are going to.
If you're doing something like fracking is generating billions of dollars and
you have to pay off a million here,
a million there because you fuck up some guys farm.
That's not that big of a deal.
You know that's not the answer.
The answer is not.
You can give them money or they can give you money because they ruin your life.
Well if you.
If if you say,
okay,
we're not going to have any fracking because a couple of farms got fucked up.
Okay.
If that's the tradeoff,
if we value those forms that heavily with the whole nation is going to be worse
off including those far because I'm sure the farmers will get compensated.
I don't even know the particular situation and talk about,
but you know how many farmers are now multimillionaires because they lived in
North Dakota and now they can frack instead of farm.
I mean,
so many farmers are are making a fortune and you're trying to find the one that
that suffering,
but I can.
I can show you many more.
There are a lot more.
The earth itself,
the earth,
forget about the what whether we frack or not,
frank,
that the wildlife or the fresh water,
all those things that poop poisoning,
that stuff is bad.
It's a big kind of chuckle about.
I don't think the earth is going to,
you know,
obviously it can't care,
but I don't think we're going to destroy the planet.
You know,
whether or not we frack or not you,
I don't think it's going to,
in the scheme of things,
make a difference in our,
in our ecosystem or our environment can let me know.
We'll make a difference in our standard of living.
That's for sure.
Let me ask you a question.
Okay.
Let's say let's pick a lake.
Lake Michigan.
Okay.
Say if you,
if there was something that you could do that with guaranteed.
Kill every fish in Lake Michigan forever,
but provide massive economic prosperity to everyone else in the country.
Lift us out of a recession.
Would you be in favor of doing it?
Well,
what kind of prosperity you talking about?
She's just like the fucking best.
It's ever been times 10.
So you're telling those kills off everything in Lake Michigan,
everything near the lake is dead.
You can't do no fishing,
no camp,
but everybody else.
It's like you're talking like roaring 20 [inaudible] like the jetsons.
I'm talking about a future Utopian world and all we got to sacrifice as
deficient and forever just in that one leg.
Yup.
Forever probably.
Sounds like a decent chance of terrible trade off.
Is that the only way we could do it?
No,
but no,
but you're telling me you care more about those fish than all then your fellow
human being though I have more faith in my fellow human being.
Sorry.
I think it's possible for us to achieve prosperity without killing the fun out
of everything in Lake Michigan.
But that's not the trade off.
You told me,
you said if we get it instantaneously,
create all this.
Well those fish trap.
Hi.
No,
but no,
but I.
But I hold human life more valuable than than a fish.
We eat fish,
right?
I don't need human beings.
I have.
I probably eat fish more than anything else.
Of course you understand though,
as an intelligent man that the ecosystem is incredibly complex and when you kill
off an entire lake,
you don't just affect the fish.
You affect everything anywhere near.
In fact,
probably the whole contract,
I doubt.
I doubt the whole country would collapse if we didn't have that one collapsed.
We could adapt human beings.
We're incredibly in.
You said we were going to have a massive,
you know,
tenfold increase in our collective standard of living.
We're going to pull those out.
But doesn't that mean by definition that we didn't have any downside from the
loss of one of the Great Lakes,
the Great Lakes itself,
the lake itself is fucked.
One of the great wonders of.
But you told us that everybody else would.
We would all be better off including the people who used to live by the lake
because just because some,
because everybody will be better off,
doesn't mean that's the only way we could do it.
I think there could be a way to do that without doing that and that should be
pursued above all else.
The idea of figuring out a way to make this world better without polluting it.
Well,
we already know how to make the world better.
I mean it's freedom.
It's the freer we are,
the more prosperous we're going to be and the enemy of freedom is government
right now.
If you have a little bit of government,
that's a good thing.
If you have just enough government to secure your freedoms and secure your
liberties,
then you have prosperity but too much government then it's an impediment to
liberty and prosperity.
But what we should really be talking about is what's going to happen.
You know,
and you've got all this propaganda out there by the government that is being
spread by,
you know,
by Wall Street as well.
That what Ben Bernanke,
he has done his work that we've got a real economic recovery that the jobs are
on their way,
that there no inflation.
All of this is wrong.
The economy is suffering because
of what the government is doing.
There is no recovery.
I think we're in a depression.
I think we've been at the depression the whole time.
I think the numbers are manipulated.
I think the government is understating the true rate of inflation,
so that means it looks like the economy is growing,
but it's actually contracting.
That's why the labor forces is imploding.
That's why people,
you know,
there was no good jobs.
That's why people have a following,
a standard of living of people feel like it's a recession because it is.
The government is trying to pretend that it's not because they point to the
stock market,
but so what stocks are going up doesn't mean anything.
I mean it's not even that earnings are going up.
Corporations aren't really earning more money just to stock prices are going up
and there are a lot of people would say,
well,
the corporations have a lot of cash.
Well,
because they borrowed it,
they only have that cash because they issued debt.
Corporations now have more debt than ever before.
Even if you net out the cash,
the government has more debt than ever before.
Americans have more debt.
Look at all the student loans we have.
Look at the mortgage debt,
credit card debt,
we are leveraged up to the hilt and the only way we keep this thing going is
because we can borrow more because the people loaning us the money.
Don't realize that we're too broke to pay it back,
but he like apple that has billions of dollars.
Look,
apple's a good company.
How many companies are like that out?
They're not that many w.
We need more of them.
How many do you think there are that,
that have like a pile of cash?
Not that many because most of them have cash,
but then they have debt.
Okay.
Apple just issued a bunch of debt.
By the way they,
they,
they issued longterm debt.
So some of that cash they borrowed.
Um,
but you know,
a lot of the cash that apple has is offshore.
They can't even bring it home because the tax rates would kill him.
So the tax,
the money is out of the country.
When you see things like France imposing a 75 percent tax on the very wealthy,
does that freak you out?
Well,
it's not that much lower here.
I mean,
you're living in California,
right?
So the California income tax is 13 point three is the top,
but the federal,
what's the federal tax?
It's 39 point nine.
So call it 40 plus you get another four percent for obamacare.
So you got 44 percent federal tax.
Obamacare,
really four percent.
So four percent extra,
three point nine.
So called force.
You've got 44 percent federal tax,
then you add California,
right?
So 44,
57.
So you're at like 57 percent marginal tax rate in California,
but that's just your income tax.
What about,
you know,
what about your property taxes,
your sales taxes,
all the other taxes you pay.
I mean the government's taken 57 percent and then out of the 43 percent you got
left.
You know,
I was looking at listening to one of your other podcasts and you were talking
and you said something like,
look,
you know,
I don't want the government to take half more than half or something like that.
Why half?
Why do you know a medieval serf?
And this is futile system of serfdom,
which was considered very repressive.
You know,
in the Middle Ages,
if you were a serf,
you had to give the Lord 25 percent of what you produced 20,
so you were in the 25 percent tax bracket and you got to keep seventy five cents
on the dollar and that was considered exploitation.
What I would give to be,
I would love to be able to be as free as a surf.
If the government just treated me like a lord treated the surf,
it'd be.
That'd be awesome.
My,
they have to cut my taxes in half to get my tax bracket down to just 25 percent
so I could be a surf.
But at one point in America,
the government took nothing,
nothing.
In fact,
when they first created the income tax right in 1913,
eight,
it got an income tax a hundred years ago.
The reason that they created it was because the government told average
Americans,
if we tax the top one percent of the top one percent,
it was a tiny tax.
You had to earn something like the equivalent of like $2 million a year before
you had to get into the one percent bracket and the top bracket was seven
percent,
but what Congress told the average American is that if we can tax the very
wealthy a tiny bit,
you won't have to pay any taxes at all.
We'll get rid of all of the duties and the import taxes and all of the federal
government because the federal government was tiny back then they said,
we'll pay for everything just by a tiny little tax on the rich.
Okay.
Now the income tax taxes,
the average guy at rates far in excess of anything contemplated for the
rockefellers,
the vanderbilts.
I mean,
you know,
we got caught.
That was the original,
you know,
99 percent versus the one percent,
right?
Because the 99 percent wanted the income tax on the one percent and now they're
clobbered with tax rates that nobody would have even considered because the top
tax bracket initially was seven percent.
That was as high as it went.
And of course,
you know,
there was no social security taxes back then.
There were no state income taxes,
so Americans were really free.
You kept it all.
Well,
everything you weren't.
I'm with you that I think we pay too much in taxes,
but my question would be how would we run this country if we didn't have all
that money going and how do we run it back then?
It's a different country or less people.
There's far less,
right?
I mean,
isn't that funny?
Population was growing faster.
I mean you,
you think about how we were able to win the Second World War because you
mentioned,
you know,
we,
we kicked the crap out of Japan,
Germany,
we single handled,
we fought wars in the Pacific and in Europe.
Where did all the factories come from to produce all those planes and those
tanks and those bombs.
I mean the government didn't create the free market built up that,
that arsenal.
We had the industry that enabled us to go and,
and,
and when those wars.
But that happened without government.
It happened,
you know,
it was in the absence of government because government was,
was,
was caught in a cage.
They couldn't interfere.
And so we created all this wealth.
The country ran very,
very well up until night.
The 19 twenties,
19 thirties,
you know,
we had a great country,
go back and look at the 18 nineties,
nineties decades were phenomenal economic growth.
Now when people say,
well Peter,
shift,
you want to go back to the 18 nineties,
I don't want to go back to the 18 nineties technology clearly.
Right?
We've benefited from the technological advancements that have taken place.
But if we had,
if we had the same amount of government today is we had back then,
we would have much more in the way of technology.
We would have a much better standard of living.
We would all be.
I think the environment would be much better shape.
We'd have a cleaner environment.
Had we been able to progress at the rate that we,
we were progressing back
then.
How do you,
how do you feel the Murray?
Because the wealthier you are,
the more you can take care of your environment because it takes,
it takes,
it takes well to be able to do it.
And we would be a wealthier country today if we were freer,
if we didn't have to keep us from taking care of our environment as wealth.
Yeah.
I think if we are.
You look at some of the poorest countries,
they don't have any money to take care of their environment.
Now I guess if you're so poor that you can't do anything.
I mean maybe the environment was pretty good in the stone age,
but when you want to be in the stone age,
what more gunk countries are more economically prosperous than us.
And how fall?
There are a lot of boat.
There are a lot of countries that have that.
Well China,
China,
how fucked up is trying to environment pretty bad.
It is pretty bad.
But you know,
and they're richer than us right now.
Right?
Well not on a per capita basis,
but kind of Richard the knots right now.
Well they are doing better than us because they don't have any regulation there.
Completely not knowing their environment.
They don't.
It's not that they don't have any regulation.
If they do,
they actually have less than us though,
which is why they're producing so much.
That's why they have fucking no skies that are black.
I mean literally you drive down the street and see half the people in masks on.
Yeah,
I know and all this stuff they're producing.
We get it here in America.
We are going towards producing over the environment.
You're doing that.
Again,
you immediately side towards this is the glass half full assay either producing
all these things.
They're making all this money.
I think
if the Chinese weren't obsessed with selling stuff to Americans who can't afford
to pay for it,
if they simply let their currency go up in value,
right,
their own citizens would be able to consume those products and they'd have a lot
more wealth to take care of their environment.
I think they're,
they're.
They're sacrificing to keep our economy propped up and I think that
are people going,
what are they going to do for a living?
So many of these people are actually making things for Americans.
They're going to stop and just concentrate on their economy and concentrated
will.
We'll have to go back.
I'll go back to world war two.
Right?
So during the Second World War,
right,
Americans were employed either if you were a man,
you were in the army,
if you were a one.
I mean if you were four f you or you were working for factor that made bombs,
women,
right,
who were formerly housewives for now in factories working,
making bombs.
So everybody had jobs.
Everybody was making stuff for the war.
Uh,
meanwhile,
everything that you needed was rationed at home.
It was very tough being in the U,
s during the war because we had nothing because everything was used,
uh,
to,
to supply the war.
Now as the war was nearing an end,
there are a lot of economists who were advising the president,
your President Truman,
you know,
we can end the war because there's going to be massive unemployment because all
the soldiers are going to be unemployed.
The people making bombs are going to be unemployed.
We know what are we going to do?
And they were actually worried about this is so stupid.
It was to have economic advisors.
But um,
but then the war ended and did we have a collapse?
No,
we had a boom because now all the people that were making stuff that blew up
started to make things that we actually wanted.
Right.
And so pigeons of those industries were in fact in war,
right?
No,
no,
no.
It was when I would start it off.
No,
no,
no.
That,
that,
that we had factories were making automobiles
before the war.
Those,
all those factories started making tanks.
We were making commercial airplanes.
We started to make military airplanes.
So the factories came for a civilian purpose.
And then they were retrofitted for military purpose.
When the government started ordering all this stuff,
didn't the government give the economy a bump?
I know by buying this stuff.
No,
no,
no.
The economy suffered because of all those resources being squandered by the
government.
Now maybe we needed to do that.
Maybe we needed to get rid of Adolf Hitler.
Maybe we needed to fight that.
But Peter Schiff.
Well,
I'm talking about the things you could say that we're better off in the long run
because we got rid of Adolf Hitler.
But in the short run,
the fact that we had to divert all those resources out of peacetime production
to military production was,
was a burden on the economy.
People suffered during the war.
Now they,
you know,
they didn't complain because we were.
The war was on.
But this is my point about China right now.
You have all these factories in China and the Chinese are working there,
but the stuff that they're making is going to America.
It's Kinda like when we had factories and we were making stuff for,
for the war,
they're making stuff that they can't use it,
you know,
we're using it now.
If they let their own currency go up because the Chinese government is actively
suppressing the value of their currency.
That's why they have 4 trillion in foreign reserves.
That's why China is the biggest owner of us treasuries other than the Federal
Reserve,
because they keep buying them up in order to keep their currency from going up.
But when they keep their currency from going up,
they keep their own citizens from buying their own products.
But if the Chinese let their currency go up,
the the idea is that,
well,
if Americans now you know,
can't afford to buy Chinese products,
all those Chinese workers are going to lose their jobs.
No,
they won't.
Just like the soldiers didn't lose.
The factory's still there,
they just made stuff for American.
So you've got all these factories that Chinese people,
there's almost a billion people in China.
They need a lot more stuff than we do.
They need all the stuff that they're producing in those factories.
They don't need us to consume it.
They're perfectly happy to consume that stuff.
The reason they can't consume it as they can't afford it because their currency
is too weak,
but the Chinese government less their currency go up and now all of a sudden the
Chinese are going to have the jobs and the stuff.
See Right now they get the jobs and we get the stuff that's a lousy trade off
for them,
but it's good for us because we get stuff without having to work for it.
They get to work without any of this stuff.
But that's what you want when you.
When you have a job,
you don't want the job,
you want the stuff that you can buy with your paycheck.
Nobody works.
You know?
Most people don't work because they enjoy work.
They,
they,
they look forward to quitting time.
They look forward to the weekend,
they want to spend the money,
and right now the Chinese aren't able to spend it because we're spending it for
him.
Wait,
but how do you stop this?
Look at these images.
What images?
These images of pollution in China,
how would you stop that?
Because obviously they have less regulation than us and this is the result of
it.
They have slaves.
Pennies an hour.
They don't have of the environment.
Might as well be slaves.
Oh,
they're not in these factories.
What is it called?
Foxconn.
I had a woman on my,
I forget her name,
she was Chinese American and she lived with a Chinese peasants for wild.
She wrote a book and I asked her,
I said,
look,
you know,
because these are all these young girls.
It was about Chinese women and they would leave the farms and they would go and
live in cities and work at work in these factories.
And I asked her,
you know,
and they're,
they're very happy.
Their lives are much better.
Uh,
you know,
they're,
they're out on their own.
They were able to leave their home.
They are,
they aren't,
they,
the companies are taking care of their room and board.
They have plenty of spending.
My,
they have no debt.
They have fun.
They go out.
I mean they're,
they're actually enjoying their lives.
I mean,
and,
and they're now young Americans.
I mean,
there are two broke.
They're living in their parents' basements.
They can't get out from under their college debt
stories like this,
but there's not a bunch of slaves.
And you understand,
you're a very smart guy and you understand what you're doing here.
You're flavoring this argument by these anecdotal stories about this person is
so much happier now.
And I knew a lady who knew the peasants and peasants are happy.
You know,
that's what rich people saying when they don't have to live in China.
I look,
look at that fucking sky over there.
She uses and you know that.
And when the Chinese cut the cord from the United States,
when they stopped subsidizing our economy,
when they let their currency go up,
they will be able to deal with air pollution and they're also going to enjoy a
greater benefit for their efforts.
But nobody.
But nobody puts it.
If somebody in China right moves from a form into,
into,
into a city and gets a job at a factory,
nobody is forcing them to do that.
They wouldn't do that if they're live didn't improve as a result of doing it.
I'm now their lives would be a lot better if the government didn't suppress
their currency,
but America's lives would be a lot worse.
And unfortunately that is what's going to come.
Right.
Because we are living right know,
because of all the,
all,
all of their production.
Right?
And so imagine what it would be like in America,
right?
If we couldn't,
if we could only consume the things that our own factories could produce.
So what,
you know,
what if,
what if Walmart only has stuff made in America on the shelves?
I mean,
what could you buy?
Not much.
Not as much.
Well,
no,
barely you.
I mean,
you certainly couldn't buy anything that plugs in,
right?
You couldn't buy anything that,
that was electronic or they've had an on off switch or something,
but you couldn't buy much in the way of,
of furniture or clothing.
Assume that just like the regular market itself.
Like you feel like if government regulation stepped out,
if we had less imports,
we would pick up the slack with American.
Well instruction and innovation and by designing of new materials.
Well,
not with,
not with the regulatory and tax system we have now.
That's why the businesses left because you know,
and,
and so what would happen is yes we would have to produce it ourselves,
but we would produce a lot less of it at a much,
much higher costs because manufacturing be impeded by governor.
It'd be much more expensive.
And so,
you know,
you wouldn't have middle class people,
walking out of Walmart with,
you know,
with a,
with the shopping cart
slum,
but you can't say things like,
the reason why people go from farms to cities is because they make a choice.
So that's a good show.
And they made a choice because it's better for them that yes,
these people are fucked.
Like they're in a terrible,
terrible,
terrible situation and horrible spot on earth economic depression beyond,
for the average
user.
That is that.
But I mean,
the,
the human kid,
that's,
you know,
the human condition,
you don't,
you don't have anything when you know,
when you first start out,
right?
You've got to improve your life.
You make decisions that that's why what I was at occupy Wall Street,
this decision that they're making allows them to make $5 a week and jump off
buildings.
That decision,
no,
but that.
But that's a better opportunity than the one that they've,
that they gave up.
They both suck.
But this idea that your anecdotal story,
but I had a friend who she lived with and they're all happy.
What are the over in America?
People just don't make any money or a lot of governments on your.
Forget about China.
There are people here in America to a good example though,
isn't it?
Let me bring this back to home so I don't have to talk about an anecdote.
So,
uh,
there's a big movement now.
A lot of people are saying that people that work in the fast food industry or
people that work at Walmart should be paid more money.
They shouldn't be paid the minimum wage.
And of course there should be no minimum wage.
The minimum wage is,
does a lot of harm.
It's one of the stupidest laws that we've got a.
But there are people say,
look,
they should,
we should pay pay.
The more they're being exploited,
right?
They should get paid $15 an hour,
whatever it is.
But if somebody has a job at Walmart and Walmart's pain,
um,
you know,
8:50,
an hour,
$9 an hour,
whatever it is.
And they took that job,
they took that job because Walmart offered them a better deal than anybody else
because if somebody's off,
I'll offer them a better deal where they would have taken that job instead.
So the fact that somebody voluntarily accepted a job at a given rate of pay
means that they're not being exploited.
Nobody volunteers to be exploited.
If that's the best job you can get,
then you should be thankful that Walmart is.
They're offering it because they outbid everybody else.
They're offering you a better deal than you can get someplace else.
Well,
the idea is to keep away from some sort of a Fox con type scenario.
We're one group has a gigantic amount of money and they take advantage of these
incredibly poor people,
but how are they nominate a tiny,
tiny,
tiny amount of money and forcing them to work ungodly hours to the point where
they have to put nets all around their building right there.
No,
but if,
if I,
if I do not agree that it's a strange situation,
if I advertise a job at a particular rate of pay and somebody shows up,
you know when Walmart runs an ad,
they get like,
I don't know,
50 applicants per position.
So obviously they're not trying.
They're not exploiting people.
I mean,
you know,
50 people wouldn't apply for the job.
You know,
Walmart was out there and getting people and they had people with guns standing
around the workers making sure that they didn't leave and then you'd have a
point,
but nobody is forcing anybody to take these jobs.
They're taking them because it's the best job they can get.
And why is that and why is Walmart bad for offering somebody the best job they
can get?
Now?
Some people will say,
well,
they should offer even more money.
Why the worker not worth it?
They don't have enough productivity.
They don't have enough skills.
And you do a lot of people,
and this is what I did with occupy Wall Street,
but a lot of people who want to criticize people who hire people and they said,
look,
you don't pay your workers enough money.
They don't have any employees.
They don't pay their workers anything.
I said,
look,
you don't think the guy at Walmart is making enough money.
Then you hire them and pay them more.
So how to sound like Foxconn happen.
How do you have a gigantic business and makes billions of dollars and pays
people pennies and met,
makes them work 16 hours a day.
Takes advantage of these people that don't have any other opportunity.
Makes anybody work six hours a day.
They don't have to.
Who are you talking about?
Foxconn.
People don't have ungodly hours that they work.
I don't know what their hours are,
but there no one's forced to work the hours they choose to work the hours that I
don't think they have a lot of choice.
I think if we want to keep their job,
they have to do it right.
If they want to keep their job and they must like it and there's many other
opportunities,
but then they shouldn't be glad they got that one.
Oh Wow.
But are they should be glad that someone's paying them pennies.
Well,
if that's this big evil corporation,
this is the idea that people have.
Okay,
but what does that company,
okay?
What did that quote come to those?
And they're,
they're doing what they'd done for thousands of years,
but obviously the company is an improvement over what they were doing or they
wouldn't choose to work there.
And what happens is you can't make that leap,
but unless you're in that environment and you understand those people,
and I'm assuming that people are rational and I don't want a super impose my
judgment over somebody else's.
If somebody makes a decision,
again,
just like you want to choose to smoke marijuana,
right?
Fun.
Bringing that up,
man.
You know what you mean?
Nervous.
No,
because you want to make a choice and I agree.
You should have that choice.
Well,
I don't drink coffee apps.
I don't want to make things I want to do.
I don't want them to,
I don't wanna I don't want to make caffeine illegal because that's not because
marijuana is illegal in California.
Well only it's only medical.
You Got A.
Yeah.
Well,
but in some places even that,
but there's other.
Look,
I think they,
I think cocaine should be legal.
I think heroin should be legal,
right?
That doesn't mean I think people should go out and shoot up.
Right.
But,
but I recognize all the damage that the government does.
Not only is it infringement on,
on,
on liberty,
I think people should be able to choose to make a bad decision if that's what
they want to do
it.
Colorado,
North Korea,
alright,
well then they got something right over there.
But,
you know,
but that doesn't my arguments right out the window,
but it's,
you know,
but I'm not that.
I forgot.
I forgot what I was.
Yeah.
So the government,
but the government not only,
uh,
you know,
does,
uh,
does that infringe upon your liberties and freedoms,
but it actually creates a lot of problems.
The biggest problems in America is not drugs,
but the war on drugs.
Right.
That's the,
that's what does a lot much more harm to the economy.
In fact,
I actually think that more people do drugs because they're illegal than if they
were,
they'd probably,
if they were legal,
but certainly they would be safer if they were illegal.
We wouldn't be dealing with criminals,
you know,
I'd rather buy drugs from accompany a pharmaceutical company then from a gang in
south central La.
I mean,
I think they're,
they're going to be more concerned about the brand and the and the purity of
their products than the crips or the bloods or wherever.
You know,
you have to go to,
to buy your heroin down here.
So,
you know,
I and I and what I,
Johnson and Johnson,
we have the best heroin.
Well,
whatever,
I don't.
Whatever I don't want.
Look nobody,
nobody.
People here,
you know,
you get your car ripped off,
someone steals your radio or they break into your house.
Why?
Because they need money to buy illegal drugs.
If drugs were free,
there'd be a lot less expensive.
You wouldn't have to steal to buy it.
Right?
You can buy it,
you know.
So now you have all kinds of victims,
meaning drugs.
When you say free meaning legal drugs,
if drugs were legal,
they would be a lot less expensive.
Right?
And so drug addicts wouldn't have to commit crimes to support their habit.
Well,
this is subsided
by the prohibition,
right?
It's very obvious that the prohibition propped up sorts of illegal activities
that Al Capone,
of course.
I mean that's where it started,
but.
But you've got.
And in fact,
if you know the,
the,
the people who would be most against legalizing drugs is organized crime because
that takes away all their money.
Well,
here's their argument against that.
Do you know the situation in Florida where Florida for the longest time didn't
have a database?
They had these things called pain management centers where people would go in
and they would say,
oh,
my head hurts.
Oh,
okay.
We'll go right next door.
I'll write you up some oxycontin.
And they would go to in the same facility,
they'd go to a doctor and then to the pharmacist that only prescribed pain
pills.
And because of that,
they have this massive amount of people that are addicted to Oxycontin is in
Florida.
In fact,
there's an area of Florida leading up to the northern states that's called the
oxycontin express.
Vanguard actually did a show in it called the oxycontin express and we had them
on the podcast and talked about it and it's,
there's 90 percent of all oxycontin in the country is prescribed in Florida.
I mean,
and why is that?
It's because of deregulation.
It's because of a lack of regulation is because they weren't forced to have a
database where they made sure that people weren't doing something unethical and
just prescribing pain pills all willy nilly.
And that kind of goes against your theory.
Well,
I don't know that it goes against.
So I got,
I am not really familiar with it because I'm hearing about it for the first time
from you.
So I don't know,
but I know it's not that there was no regulation down there because obviously
these are doctors.
If they're writing prescriptions,
uh,
there is a lot of regulation,
you know,
involved in that process.
So I'm not familiar with it to really comment on it.
Well,
okay,
well then then that's unfair to try to bring it up to you,
but that,
that is a huge issue and it's an issue in Florida because Florida is such a
fucking.
But I do believe that the war on drugs is destroyed.
Our inner cities.
It's corrupted police forces.
It's screwed up a police,
uh,
south of the border and now you have a situation to where your inner city kid
and you know you've got minimum wage laws and you've got occupational licensing
laws that make it almost impossible for young kid to get a legitimate job yet
you've got the gang bangers flashing around,
you know,
a wad of cash.
Hey,
just deal drugs.
You can make a lot of money.
You think that minimum wage and the difficulty in getting licensed for certain
positions are what's keeping people down?
Of course,
minimum wages.
Keeping people down.
Absolutely.
How has that,
how has that?
Well,
because remember,
you know,
when you're young,
when you're a teenager,
right?
You don't have a lot of skills.
I mean,
you really,
you might've never had been had a job.
I mean,
and what's more important in getting a job is not necessarily the paycheck.
That's kind of secondary.
It's what you learn on the job.
And you know,
when I had my first jobs and I was working on me,
you know,
you're living at home talking about outside of high school or in high school,
the all that's important is the money's the only thing that's.
No,
no,
no.
I mean when we,
when you are,
look,
you want the money,
right?
Because you want money for,
to take a girl out on a date or maybe you need gas money,
right?
But you don't need rent money.
You're living at home.
You don't need food.
Your,
your overhead is taking care of.
The real benefit is acquiring skills on the job training that will enable you to
earn more money as you get older and take on more responsibility in these
skills.
When you're working at a burger joint,
what am I.
What skills am I getting?
Working at Newport creamery,
there are a lot like.
I'll give you an example of gas stations because gas stations are good example.
I worked at a gas station because at one point in time there were a lot of jobs
for young kids at gas stations and,
and,
and they work mainly for tips.
You know,
you,
they would pump gas,
they would check the air in the tires,
they'd wash your windows and they didn't make very much,
but between Philips and these were the pump jockeys,
right between Phillips,
maybe they worked with a mechanic and they helped out to mechanics and you know,
a lot of auto mechanics got their start as a,
you know,
pumped jockeys and you know,
and you know,
eventually,
you know,
they were able to become a mechanic and they can earn more money as some of them
may be eventually opened up their own gas station and you know,
became entrepreneurs and had a few,
but they got started,
uh,
you know,
at an entry level position.
Now of course,
the minimum wage law,
it's all self serve.
I mean,
you go to a gas station,
there's no human beings there.
Maybe there's one guy that's in a little booth that's Kinda overseeing,
but you know,
if you want to check your air in your tire,
you do yourself,
you want to wash your windows,
you wash your own windows.
All those jobs had been eliminated by the minimum wage,
but so as the opportunities that came with them and now if you want to get a
mechanic where you got to go to vocational school,
you got to pay money,
you got to go into debt,
you know,
maybe you can learn to be a mechanic,
but you know,
on the job training was how young people use to acquire skills in and now we've
got all those guys going to college.
They get a philosophy degree.
You know,
they spend six years,
you know,
barfing at frat parties,
but they graduate with a huge debt.
They know nothing.
You know,
a lot of them would have been better off getting a,
getting a low paying job and learning how to do something.
During this time of this,
when people did learn how to be a mechanic by becoming a pump jockey,
there was a minimum wage in effect.
Well,
the minimum wage in America didn't start until 1938,
but I was at a gas station,
I know,
but let me minimum wage.
It started in 1938 and it only affected some certain federal workers.
It wasn't,
and it was 25,
twenty five cents an hour.
It didn't apply to most workers until the mid 19 sixties.
So it was the war on poverty that really brought about the,
um,
the minimum wage.
So,
and,
and of course over time,
as the minimum wage got higher and higher during the sixties and seventies,
that's when it really began to take a bigger toll.
But at,
like if you look now at like black teenage unemployment,
which is off the charts,
which is what,
50,
60,
70 percent of much exactly what it is.
But if you go back before the minimum wage,
right?
Black teenage unemployment was 15 percent,
it was actually lower than white teenage unemployment.
Um,
and,
and all this stuff,
you take it,
you,
you take the bottom rung off the job ladder and you just obliterate it,
you just make it impossible for young,
unskilled people to get a job.
And it's not just a minimum wage because that's the beginning,
right?
Because if you employ somebody at the minimum wage,
you still got to pay payroll taxes,
you gotta pay unemployment taxes,
you've got other mandated costs,
legal costs that increase the cost of hiring.
So maybe even though the minimum wage is seven,
25 an hour,
it may be a cost you 10 bucks to hire the guy an hour,
even though you only give them seven.
Twenty five is cost you 10 bucks.
What if,
what if their productivity is only worth $6?
You can't hire him.
It's impossible.
You're not going to hire him to lose money.
You're not going to train somebody.
I mean,
you know,
there are a lot of people,
these success stories,
you know,
people go from the mail room to the board room,
it's harder to start,
you know,
at the bottom because it's hard to get your foot on the bottom right because you
know,
you have to be at a much higher level and it disproportionately impacts poor
kids.
Inner City kids,
uh,
you know,
and,
and it favors these minimum wage laws will favor skilled workers over unskilled
workers because if I have to pay a certain wage,
well then maybe I'll hire somebody that has more skill.
In fact,
it was the skilled workers,
the labor unions that lobbied for the minimum wage,
not because it benefited them because they made much more than minimum wage.
What they wanted to do is make it expensive to hire unskilled labor.
So you wouldn't hire the unskilled labor,
you would just hire the union labor.
I see what you're saying.
So what you're saying essentially is that minimum wages is more government
intrusion and the more freedom that you have the government take away from you,
whether it's minimum wage freedom,
whether it's tax free,
whatever it is the worst is going to be,
you're going to have more regulations,
you're going to have more people involved,
more red tape,
more bullshit,
more waste.
Yeah,
I should have a right to work,
you know,
if you know,
if I want to write it,
you know,
and look,
the interesting thing,
look at all these lawsuits now,
the internships in the entertainment industry,
you know,
this has the perverse effect of it.
So the government made it illegal to pay somebody below the minimum wage,
but it was okay if they worked for free.
Right?
So now you have all these interns who probably would have been paid something if
it wasn't for the minimum wage,
but since it was illegal to pay them something,
they ended up working for nothing.
Of course,
now they're suing and they're winning lawsuits say,
hey,
you have to pay me.
So now they're going to destroy the internships.
And now a lot of these companies that used to have internships aren't going to
have them anyway.
Don't the interns get college credit?
It wasn't that the whole idea behind it.
Some of them do,
but then.
But then that was even worse because what would happen sometimes in order to
keep themselves safe because the employers didn't want to run a foul of the
employment law.
So they would only give you the internship if you got it through a college.
Right.
So now what would happen is you'd actually have to pay to be an intern because
you'd go and pay tuition to a college just so you can go and work for free.
I mean,
wouldn't it be better not to pay the tuition and go into debt and just work for
a low wage than to pay to work for no wage.
I mean,
this is what happens when you have all these government regulations.
Everybody is worse off.
And you know,
people,
people think,
oh these young people are being exploited.
No,
they're not.
It's not exploitation in.
A lot of times it's the best thing that can happen to them is they get a job and
you know,
people say,
well,
you know,
you can't raise a family on the minimum wage.
Of course not.
And you shouldn't even try.
I mean,
if all you can do is flip burgers,
why are you starting a family?
I mean,
you should,
you know,
you,
you got to develop your skills.
You got to be able
to earn more money than that before you take on those extra responsibilities.
But if you say,
hey,
every wage has to be a wage that could let you know,
support a family,
then there are no entry level jobs.
Well then how do you enter the labor market if there's no entry level position,
you know,
well,
if you're in a situation like a fast food Gig,
I mean,
where does that lead to the manager?
what,
how do you know,
rise through the ranks at a fast food.
Some people write,
some people start out,
you know,
uh,
cooking French fries or mopping up and,
and go onto b if own a franchise.
I mean,
so you can certainly move up and there are people,
uh,
I think the guy who's about to be this,
the new CEO of Walmart,
his first job was working on a loading dock and what are the distribution
centers and now he's the be as CEO.
He worked his way up to the very top of the call.
You went to college.
Uh,
but I mean that's not,
but that's how he got his foot in the door and I probably,
you know,
but,
but the,
I mean they wouldn't have hired him to run the company and let's,
maybe,
but I don't know,
but maybe,
maybe,
maybe the fact that he worked there,
gave,
maybe that gave him a leg up to making sure that definitely had an impact.
But if you take a look at something that works at Mcdonald's,
you don't necessarily have to work up the chain of Mcdonald's.
Mcdonald's could be your first job.
Look,
what were my first jobs?
I delivered groceries.
I bagged groceries.
I,
uh,
I sold a clothing retail in the mall.
I sold shoes.
I sold cable door to door.
And they say,
well,
you know,
did I move up in the know,
but I,
I ended up getting other jobs where,
you know,
the sales skills were important,
uh,
you know,
you get you just,
even when I got my first job at a supermarket and a lot of times I was just
mopping up the floors.
I was bagging the groceries and I would deliver the groceries.
But you just learn to show up at time,
you know,
and now you have something that you've done.
I mean,
a lot of it.
So you get a job at Mcdonald's and then you get a job someplace else.
That's better because,
well,
what did you do before you were here?
Well,
I worked at Mcdonald's.
How long were you there?
I was there for a couple of years.
In fact,
I still have the job.
Oh well that means at least you didn't get fired.
You have the job.
I mean,
you've got something.
You've got to start somewhere.
Everybody starts somewhere and you can't expect to get paid a lot of money when
you first start out.
You've got to make yourself more valuable because what you are when individuals,
we sell our labor to the highest bidder,
you know,
and so what you have to do is you've got to figure out how can I increase my
value to a potential employer so that he'll pay me more money but isn't the idea
of minimum wage just to keep it from being gross,
not make it so it is low.
$15 an hour is pretty low.
It's incredibly difficult to make a living getting $15 an hour.
But I must say you don't have to make a living and feed yourself if,
if,
if they,
if they enforced a minimum wage of $15 an hour on like Mcdonald's,
there would be no human beings working there.
It would all be automated.
They wouldn't,
you know,
there might be one guy there that made sure that the robots didn't,
uh,
you know,
didn't break down,
but you know,
there'd be machines making a hamburger is make it a French fries.
Wouldn't be like a gas station.
Wouldn't that be good?
Just like we were talking about deregulation and the government forcing them to
get real jobs for the people that work in the fast food burger king and get them
out there,
but then they would.
What would they do then just go on welfare for them.
Figure out a way to get a real job,
but no,
but that is their entry to the job market.
I mean they have no skills.
Look,
believe me,
if these people had better skills,
would they be working at Mcdonald's?
Now?
Part of the problem is,
and this isn't,
you know that there are some people that really could be working better jobs,
but they're not because we have this phony economy that is preventing those
better jobs from being created.
That's the.
That's the problem.
There are a lot of people now that are working at Mcdonald's because that's all
they can get and you know,
it's not like,
you know,
at least they got that to fall back on.
But the problem is why aren't there better jobs?
Why aren't the jobs that would normally be there for you to work up right?
To the jobs that are higher up on the ladder,
where are those jobs?
And those jobs are being destroyed by the government because we need more
savings.
We need more capital investment.
We need higher interest rates for that to happen.
And the government is so busy inflating this bubble economy that they're sucking
all the air out of the real economy.
They're diverting resources from main street to Wall Street and they are
preventing these jobs from being created,
in fact,
are destroying a lot of the jobs that exist.
So how would you fix that if you,
if um,
Obama and I say Peter Schiff,
I heard you on the Joe Rogan experience.
You make a lot of sense as I got working for me.
Fucking suck.
Come over here man.
Sit down.
Tell me what the fuck to do.
What can I do here?
How do we fix this mess other than resigning?
But I guess if he's,
if he's actually going to list out a way to make friends,
but if he's actually going to listen to me,
that I don't want him to resign.
If he actually has that kind of epiphany.
Let's pretend,
well 10,
Jamie's the president and you've got to convince him.
Yeah,
well then you got a.
What would you tell them to do?
What would you tell him to do?
He's got to start,
you know,
repealing rules and regulations and,
and,
and shrinking government and closing down agencies and departments and laying
off government workers and government workers.
How do you,
where do you start?
I'll start at the top.
I mean,
we've got fire the president.
You want to save the company?
You've got to go under yourself.
But I said,
get rid of all of the economic advisors.
Look at the Department of Energy,
the Department of Agriculture,
the Department of Education,
assholes.
Every one of them.
Some of them are,
some of them are,
but we can't afford them and they're not helping.
They're not making the country richer.
They're making it poor.
We didn't always have these departments.
A lot of these departments weren't even created until the second half of the
20th century.
America made it without all those agencies and departments.
We didn't even have the Department of energy came in in the late 19 seventies.
I mean,
what do we need it for it?
In fact,
when we first developed the Department of Energy,
it was because we imported like 30 percent of our oil.
We said this is too much.
We have to do something about it.
So then we were report 40,
70 percent of our oil.
I mean the Department of Energy doesn't produce any energy.
I mean it just produces jobs for bureaucrats,
but there's all these agencies and departments that we can't afford.
We never needed them.
It was a way for politicians to buy votes and to peddle influence.
We got to get rid of it.
But what we also have to do is get to the Federal Reserve because interest rates
have to go up.
Well,
let's say you can have zero percent interest rate.
Let's pretend we're taking care of this right now.
So Department of Energy,
they're fucking useless.
They don't do anything for us.
Well,
they're the worst than useless.
They were useless.
That would be an improvement.
So obviously the world has changed drastically since the time when
we imported 50 percent and maybe the our needs are,
you know,
greatly disproportionate to back then as well.
That's why we need 70 percent.
But what you're saying is there's no benefit in having the department for
Education.
We would produce a lot more energy without the departments.
We'd have much better education without the department of Education and they do
read the department.
What are they getting away?
In what way?
Well,
first of all,
we have to pay their salaries.
Right?
Okay.
Pay The expensive.
It's expensive to support all these bureaucrats.
And then once they have a job,
they got to figure out something to do.
They got to make up stuff.
I mean that's how government works.
Government doesn't want to solve a problem because then there's no need for the
agency.
The minute you have a problem and you say,
okay,
let's have the government solve it,
the last thing they want to do is solve it because then there's no reason to
exist.
They want the problem to get bigger so they can demand more resources.
They can have more people.
A bigger department,
so it's like the opposite of a capitalism and it's not the survival of the
fittest.
It's,
you know,
the,
the worst you do your job,
the more you're rewarded,
right?
Uh,
and so you don't want to have government doing all these things.
You want to let the market,
you want individuals that have a vested interest.
You want the profit incentive,
you know,
uh,
the invisible hand,
all the benefits of capitalism.
You don't want to get screwed up by government.
But the thing that we have to understand is we can't have this phony service
sector,
economy.
We can't have everybody working in healthcare and education.
We can't send every kid to college.
This idea that everybody needs to go to college is nonsense.
Most people don't need to go to college.
You know,
at one point,
people,
when,
you know,
maybe,
before the Second World War,
maybe I don't know what,
I'm not even one out of 10 people went to college.
Uh,
but if you went to college is because you want it to be a doctor or you want it
to be something that you really needed to go.
I mean now you have more people waiting on tending bar,
waiting tables,
driving cab with college degrees.
Some of them have advanced degrees.
You know,
you want to get a laugh.
I did this video,
know if you saw it.
I was in New Orleans and I was working walking down Bourbon Street and I was
interviewing people and asking them,
you know,
if they graduated from college and what their major was and when they graduated
and they all did and never.
Some of them had two or three degrees and they were all,
you know,
bartenders are bouncers at strip clubs are pedicab drivers are screening the
street.
Everybody had a college degree but nobody needed it.
But they all had debt that they were working off.
I mean,
the idea that we have to send every kid to college regardless of their aptitude,
regardless of whether or not you know,
they're going to have any real benefit who benefits from this?
It's the colleges,
the universities.
The administrators that make a fortune off of all this money and the kids
graduate with a worthless degree because everybody else has one.
So who cares?
You don't know anything but you've got all this debt and are the kids better off
spending the first six years of adulthood,
you know,
in college,
and that,
you know,
a lot of them,
they move out of their parents' house because they can borrow all this money to
live off campus or Frat or live in the dorms.
But now they are 22,
23,
24 years old.
They have such a pile of debt,
they can never get out from it.
And now they're back home for good.
I mean I'd rather have kids stay at home,
you know,
after they graduate high school,
get a low paying job,
don't take on any debt,
maybe get some skills.
And then when they're 20 or 23,
then they can move out.
They can rent their own place,
they're self sufficient.
Instead they're,
you know,
the now,
now,
now they got no,
they got no options because they,
they,
they follow the government's advice.
Well,
obviously some have options and obviously some people go to college to get jobs
and I don't know what the percentage is of people that have successful careers
after college,
but I assume it's,
it's.
I mean,
we don't,
we're not dealing with a nation of constantly advancing homeless people where
every year the homeless population goes up 3 million.
Most people on college campuses have.
There's no reason for them to be there and they will not benefit from,
from being there.
Well,
I think there's a lot,
there's a growing process going on and I agree with you that if you look at the
end result,
yeah,
most of them didn't benefit from it,
but they probably did anyway because they benefited from knowing that this is
not how to get through in life.
They benefited from knowing that you,
you look,
some people that they went to college with,
I'm sure did some extensive,
a lesson for society.
I'm on this page with you there of education.
Fuck them too.
Right?
Let's get rid of them and the energy guys.
So what are we down to?
Well,
we got to get rid of a lot more,
but we got to go after the entitlements.
We've got to go after social security and Medicare.
I mean,
these are disasters.
You got to lighten up.
You want to drink?
You want a little bit on drinking?
I'm drinking alcohol.
What do you got?
A beer.
You want a little scotch?
A little whiskey,
man.
I could go for some.
Get some.
Get some whiskey for this fellow.
He needs to lighten up.
What time is it?
Plenty of times.
Don't worry about.
The Internet goes on forever and time is illusion created by the man.
They've created these fucking clocks,
so energy done.
We'll get rid of those.
We'll figure out the energy will will regulate it statewide.
That's how we'll deal with environmental concerns.
I.
Okay.
I like that education.
Let's be honest.
It's a mess,
right?
The,
the,
the levels of educations that we're accepting for high school students is
absolutely ridiculous.
I agree that college educations are insanely expensive.
The idea behind it is observed.
The idea that you can go to school for x amount of years,
come out and be more in debt and you're going to make it a decade of working
every fucking day.
We also,
we also have to let young kids off the hook for social security.
I mean they didn't vote for this pricing scheme.
It was conceived before they.
It is a Ponzi scheme.
That's all it is.
Like explain it to people who don't understand because I've seen your
explanation to the social security system and it's very enlightening because
it's disgusting what is.
Yeah,
they ought to.
They ought to build a director statue of Ponzi right into the lobby of the
Social Security Administration.
But you know,
social security was conceived and sold to the American public as a complete
fraud.
Right?
The idea initially,
and the government deliberately used this kind of language,
was that it was like insurance because the taxes that you pay are called
premiums and and they're.
And you're a beneficiary and they have a trust fund,
right?
All this is what an insurance company does,
but social security doesn't have a real trust fund.
Nothing is invested.
It's,
it's an intergenerational Ponzi scheme.
What happened is people paid into social security,
they paid social security taxes.
I get on the box on the rock
center rock.
Yeah.
You're a gentleman.
So people paid.
So Jack Daniels or what's the other stuff?
Check dams was fine.
Oh,
so,
um,
people paid social security taxes,
right?
And the government spent the money.
They didn't,
they didn't invest in anything.
They did,
they didn't put it aside in a trust fund.
They just spend the money now as the population grew and they kept raising the
task because originally it was just a one percent tax,
right?
And it didn't affect self employed people.
Right?
So it,
it didn't affect self employed people
because the government said,
look,
if you're smart enough to run your own business,
you're smart enough to save for your own retirement.
So the government was supposedly going after the average worker who wasn't going
to save any money.
So they said,
look,
we're going to save the money for you.
We're going to have a forced savings.
But of course the government didn't save anything.
They spend every nickel.
But as the year,
as the years went by,
they kept increasing the payroll tax and of course the population was growing
and so what the government does is they tax young people and,
and pay off the older people.
And of course the older people they vote,
right?
The most important thing to them is their social security check.
And so they vote for whoever promises more benefits.
And so eventually they got more goodies added on,
you know,
prescription drugs,
different things.
But the young people now are coming in at the end.
The people today,
generation x later,
you know,
you are just holding the bag,
you are at the end of the chain letter or whatever it is.
And we're paying people.
A lot of young people now pay more in social security taxes and they pay in
income taxes.
And of course you pay your employers have the,
the entire 15 percent comes out of the employee's pocket,
the employer,
just whatever money the employer,
your employer sends to the government is the money that he would have sent you
if the tax wasn't there.
Right?
So you,
it's all part of the cost of labor,
but the government did it this way so that people wouldn't realize how expensive
the social security was,
but there is absolutely no way that someone in their twenties or thirties or
forties or even probably my age 50 is going to collect.
This is gonna blow up.
This is going to collapse.
So the sooner that we can level with the public to better,
we got to end this thing.
We gotta we gotta stop the Social Security Tax,
right?
Let the young people off the hook and now we have to deal with the consequences
of a failed system.
I think we have to means test it.
I think we've got to tell wealthier people,
hey,
you know,
you basically.
What was that?
Uh,
um,
from a animal house,
hey,
you fucked up,
you trusted the government,
you know,
you're screwed.
You know,
the government made a bunch of promises that it can't keep.
We're not going to steal from your kids in order to make you whole.
So if you're rich,
if you have assets or income,
no social security check,
right?
Because we're not going to rob from the young and the poor and give to the old
and the rich.
You were dumb enough to vote for these policies,
so deal with the consequences and I would have an asset test and means test and
then if somebody is in dire situation,
maybe buy him some kind of a minimal annuity or something.
Uh,
but we got to admit that social security as well as welfare,
that's all it is.
The money comes from the same pot.
Nobody paid into anything because whatever money the government collected was
spent.
It's all gone.
Now to play devil's advocate,
the benefits of social security are that some people that made a decent ways
their whole life,
but live check to check would someday be able to stop working.
No,
they're not.
They're not going to.
What about people that are doing it right now?
Good.
There are people doing it now.
Just like any Ponzi scheme or rather a chain letter,
a pyramid.
There are people like the first person that collected social security,
her name was.
I'm a fuller,
I think,
and she lived to be 100 years old and she only paid in like,
I don't know,
20 bucks in taxes and she collected tens of thousands,
right?
She made out like a Banshee,
But you know,
it's the people that come in late,
he gets abandoned,
abandoned,
whatever it is,
but she made out,
right?
She,
you know,
she but,
but the reason that,
that pyramid schemes are illegal is because they don't work,
right?
They benefit the people that get in at the beginning,
at the expense of people to get in at the end.
Well,
if a,
if a pyramid doesn't work,
it we,
the government can't make it work.
If the government runs it,
they're not going to be more successful than the private sector.
The only difference is when you know people in a private sector figure out it's
a Ponzi scheme,
right?
But why didn't Bernie madoff's Ponzi scheme fall apart?
Because when people realize what the Ponzi scheme,
they wanted their money back.
Social Security is a Ponzi scheme.
You can't get out of the government requires you to participate at gunpoint and
even if you know it's a Ponzi scheme,
I'm paying social security taxes even though I know it's a Ponzi scheme.
If it was a free market,
I wouldn't be paying and you will have to be able to say whether or not you
wanted to contribute and benefit from it.
It's like an opt in.
If you have an opt in thing,
would you be willing?
I would opt right out.
I mean I would give up,
but yeah,
but.
But first of all,
but I don't even think the government.
Why is the government involved in social security?
There's nothing in the constitution that gives the government the authority to
take care of this.
Look.
If I want to buy insurance from my old age,
let me buy it in the private sector.
I mean know and let me save on my own money.
Go.
Where does most of the money go when you do,
but when you buy insurance?
Well,
if you buy legitimate insurance,
the money is invested and it grows so that when you that he could pay off
whether you're buying a life insurance,
fire insurance,
auto insurance companies invest the money and you know some people putting
claims,
other people don't,
but for retirement,
a funded pension system are legitimate system.
You take money as you work and you invest it,
and over time compounding interest or the investment returns eventually you know
based on your contributions and the gains and the reinvestment of the interest
and the dividends.
You accumulated a portfolio of stocks and bonds or whatever real estate,
whatever you bought,
but you can live on,
you can live off of your income from your investments.
Now,
how is that different than how social security handles it?
So secure happens when your money goes into social,
they spend it,
the government spends it on current social security recipients.
They spend it on the war in Iraq or Afghanistan,
wherever they are.
They spend it on the war on drugs that were on poverty.
So it's totally speculative because we don't get a receipt,
but there's nothing there.
But there's also what you're spending on what we call it,
just a bunch of.
Yeah.
But there's also no return because there's no.
There's no compound.
You,
you don't,
you don't generate anything.
And so the only way the government can pay you the money when you retire is if
they get and get it from somebody else.
But you know,
how is the baby bust,
right?
Generation x going to pay for the retirement of the baby boom.
It's impossible.
I mean they don't even.
I mean they don't have the incomes.
They're loaded up with debt themselves.
If you've got a bunch of college debt,
how are,
you know,
not only do you have to pay that,
but you got to pay somebody social security and their medicare,
you know,
it is impossible.
So we've got to admit the policies have to admit all the false promises that
they made in order to buy votes,
right?
That's what they do.
They promise something for nothing because that's what people vote for.
People are dumb enough to do that.
They vote for something for nothing,
but you know,
there's nothing more expensive than something you get for free from the
government and we're going to find out just how expensive all this free stuff
is.
But we got to level with people and said,
look,
you know,
there is no trust fund,
there is no money there.
And so let's end the program.
Let's stop it,
let's,
you know,
and then let's figure out how to deal with,
uh,
the people who unfortunately now because of this program now depend on this
program,
but who would have been self sufficient if the government had let them plan for
their own retirement and also deal with the unemployment and all the people that
worked in the various organizations.
Well,
no,
that's good.
Unemployment does.
They're going to get jobs because.
Yes,
because if we get rid of all these government rules and regulations,
there will be jobs for them.
I don't,
I don't want them working in government because now I have to pay their salary
if they work in the private sector.
I don't,
I don't want to employ all these bureaucrats,
you know,
especially when the average bureaucrat is making more than the average person
who's paying the taxes that pay the bureaucrats,
you know,
and they just gave everybody in Washington.
Oh,
one percent pay raise.
Who can afford that?
I mean they should be given these guys pay cuts,
but part of the deal,
uh,
to fund the government was to give everybody a raise in Washington.
They're already overpaid.
Excellent arguments.
So Department of energy dead,
Department of Education,
gone social security.
Go Fuck Yourself.
What do we have left?
How do we deal with.
Well,
you got to cut the fence massively.
That's the next question.
Yeah.
Well,
the problem with the military is it's not the department of Defense now it's
department of offense,
right?
You know,
what we need to do is minor own business,
right?
We need to stop stirring up Hornet's nest and then being surprised when we get
stung.
So Peter Schiff,
freedom and free though,
don't you know,
do you know?
I'm not saying that we're not vigilant.
I want to have a military that's strong enough that nobody's going to want to
screw with us,
and we bought.
We've got that many times over.
In fact,
all we're doing is instigating,
if we just mind our own business and protected our own borders,
right?
No one who's going to,
who's going to be dumb enough to attack America?
I mean in a real way.
I mean a terrorist.
Okay,
but what nation is going to launch a war?
Nobody.
I mean did this.
There is no threat.
This is ridiculous,
but we are creating threats that wouldn't exist if we had a more defensive
posture.
Why do we have all these bases all over Europe?
I mean,
the Soviet Union is gone.
This is the problem.
It's like once you create a government department,
they never go away.
So we have all this,
this NATO.
We built up all this stuff in Europe because of the Soviet Union.
Soviet Union is gone.
Why are all the basis still there?
Where all the troops still there?
This is,
this was all government
bureaucracy just perpetuating itself.
I mean,
we,
we can't even afford it,
you know,
but we got it.
If Europe wants our troops there,
then let's invoice them.
Let's say,
you know what?
We got all these troops in Germany,
this is what it's gonna cost you to Germany to keep these troops there if you
think you need them.
If you don't want them then we're going home and you know,
but that's what we need to do.
We need that.
We need to dramatically reduce what we're spending on the military.
But I think the military should be a much higher percentage of the federal
budget than it is today,
you know,
because that's what the federal government should be doing.
Protecting us from foreigners.
Let the state governments protect us from local criminals.
Let the federal government protect us from international criminals.
But that's it.
But you know,
right now the government is doing all these things that it shouldn't do,
that it can't even do the things that it's supposed to do it effectively.
Now when you hear like the Eisenhower speech when he was leaving office and he
warned of the military industrial complex,
that's essentially what he was warning us about.
The business has arisen that profits off of war and once it becomes big like any
bureaucratic institution like any,
any gigantic corporation like anything that has too much power and influence.
Yeah.
Look,
we were the warfare state where the welfare state,
all of that has to end.
You know,
I don't want the guns or the butter from government.
Right?
I want the freedom.
I just want government to secure liberty.
That's why it's.
They're so large enough.
Percentage of money goes towards defense,
but less but less money.
A lot less.
How much less model?
No,
but I mean either we're going to run this motherfucker correctly,
but you don't have to sit down and here's what I'd like to do right
at the,
at the turn of the 19th century,
so in 1900,
19 slash 11,
the government,
federal government,
state government,
local government,
collectively all the government was five percent of our GDP right
now was this 1900.
What the fuck?
They didn't have the Internet TV,
the gum children.
That should make it gardening children.
Right?
But let's double it.
Let's let it go.
Let's let the government be 10 percent of the economy.
So let's just start slashing it.
No,
we have too much government.
Remember,
the more government you have,
the less freedom you have.
Everybody is focusing on what can I get from government?
The government doesn't give.
It has to take.
If it gives to one person has to take from somebody else.
If it legislates a special privilege for one person,
it's imposing an obligation on somebody else to pay for it.
That's not freedom.
Okay,
so what's next?
The government.
We,
we,
we set up that.
We're going to get rid of energy.
We're going to get rid of education.
We're going to get rid of change.
Alter the way we deal with defense.
Make it actually defense,
not offense.
We're down to how many,
what percentage of the economy with eliminating the government.
We've got to eliminate most of the federal government,
the federal government,
the benefit.
What do we need though?
What do we need?
What's important?
Not much nationals,
the fence,
that's it.
Just too much run by military people kind to fight phrases like,
I mean,
you know,
obviously there's some,
there's foreign embassies we can maintain.
There's certain things that we could do,
but if we,
if we do this right,
fixing the roads,
but that's local.
The federal government got nothing to do with the roads.
I mean they know is that they have to take the money
out of the states and the federal aid.
Right?
And just like trying to give yourself a blood transfusion from your right arm to
your left arm and you spill half the blood on the floor.
There's no point in doing it.
If we just,
if we could eliminate the federal government.
Think about this.
If here people in California,
if no one in California had to pay federal income taxes,
if no one had to pay social security taxes,
right?
How much more money would be here?
I mean,
we can deal with problems if you didn't have to send all the money to Washington
and beg for it back,
you know,
and it always comes back with strings attached,
you know?
And you look at these states now like Colorado where they,
you know,
they legalize marijuana but not what's just coming back to this fucking book.
But what's the federal government doing?
The federal government is making it impossible for a guy that opens up a store
to sell matter.
Rhonda,
he can't have a bank account because the banks are afraid of money laundering.
He can't rent an office.
You can't rent a storefront because of the forfeiture.
Largely if the government's to come in and seize his property.
I mean the government is federal governance trampling all over us.
I mean,
we fought a revolution to get away from that kind of stuff.
and now Washington treats us much worse than,
than the British did.
I mean King George never could have got away with this stuff.
If this is the case,
should we actually be hoping that everything falls apart?
Because in fact,
that might be the only way that all this case,
ironically.
Ironically.
Yeah,
because you know,
the thing is it's gonna fall apart,
right?
Eventually,
the sooner the better it gets,
the longer it takes,
the worst that's going to be because we are getting,
you know,
we're,
we're digging ourselves into a deeper hole every day,
right?
The sooner that the phony economy collapses,
the sooner we can start replacing it and building the legitimate economy.
So yeah,
the,
I,
I know this huge economic crash is coming.
That's way worse in 2008.
If it happens in 2014,
it won't be as bad as if it happens in 2015 and if it happens in 2016,
well that's even worse than 2015 because we're going to have that much more
debt.
It's going to be that much bigger bubble.
The bigger the bubble,
you know,
the bigger the fallout when it burst.
So the sooner we can stop doing the wrong thing,
the sooner we can start doing the right thing.
So explain to me how it does collapse.
So let's say worst case scenario,
it goes to shit in 2016.
It survives in another couple of years limping along with bandaids on.
And then one day it implodes.
What happened?
Well,
this is my best guess for how it's going to happen,
right?
So the,
the,
the economic data is going to start to come out weaker than a lot of people
think.
I think the jobs numbers are going to deteriorate.
And of course they never really improved.
Mean the reason the unemployment rate has come down,
it stopped because the unemployed have found jobs is because they've stopped
looking.
They've left the labor force and now they're collecting disability checks
instead of unemployment checks.
But the,
the,
the numbers are going to get worse.
Janet Yellen is going to be,
uh,
the Fed chairman and she is going to prescribe more quantitative using and so
they're going to reverse this tapering process and they're going to do more,
more quantitative easing.
Now everybody is assuming that the Fed is going to continue to,
uh,
to reduce these purchases and eventually unwind their balance sheet.
And of course that's impossible.
I was saying that from the beginning that you know there was no exit strategy,
that it was a lie that they had checked into a monetary roach motel that you
know,
once they had committed to this that it was,
you know,
they couldn't stop and if you live by Qe,
you die by Qe and so the Fed is going to come in and they're,
they're going to do more quantitative easing,
they're going to print more money to try to bring interest rates back down to
try to artificially stimulate the economy.
But the market is expecting to reverse to happen and as a result,
the dollar has risen a little bit.
Gold price have come down,
markets come up because people are optimistic about a legitimate recovery.
When they realized that it was false optimism and that the Fed is going to do
even more monetary stimulus because none of the other stimulus worked.
Right?
And that's what they do in Washington.
If something doesn't work,
you don't reevaluate,
you just do more of it and just assume it will work if you do it bigger.
So I think when that happens,
you're going to see a lot of downward pressure on the dollar,
it's going to really start to fall out foreign exchange markets,
and that's going to have a profound impact on consumer prices,
price of gasoline,
price of food,
stuff like that.
And now the Fed is going to be looking at CPI inflation,
which is much higher than it should tolerate,
but the Fed can't do anything.
This is the Fed raises interest rates to fight that inflation.
The stock market will crash,
the real estate market will crash and all the big banks that we bailed out are
going to fail again.
Only now they're going to have even more debt.
So we'll be at an even worse financial crisis in 2008.
So the Fed can't let that happen.
So they got to print even more money,
but now the dollar goes down even more.
And now inflation is even bigger.
And maybe for a while the government will try to convince us that inflation is
good for us and that we should be happy because at least we're not suffering
deflation.
Uh,
but at some point you're going to reach a critical point where the Fed is going
to have to either dramatically raise interest rates to protect the dollar and
stop hyperinflation and allow the markets to implode and allow a much worse
financial crisis in 2008 or they're going to keep printing the dollar until they
printed into oblivion and then it's worthless.
And then,
you know,
everybody is wiped out because no matter how much money you have,
you,
you know,
you don't even have enough money to buy a cup of coffee because the currency has
been wiped out.
Now when you deal with currency,
this is where it gets really weird with people.
Most people don't even understand what a dollar bill actually is.
And the,
they think somehow or another,
a lot of people think that it's based on something.
Not that there's like a pound of gold waiting somewhere for $100 bill or
whatever.
A lot more than a pound.
I mean,
not more than $100 obviously,
but it used to be,
right.
If you go back back
to the beginning,
if you go,
if you look at the constitution and you read a article,
one,
section eight and Article One,
section 10,
you read them,
uh,
but it says that money is gold and silver and that's what's legal tender in the
United States.
And up until 1971 a,
that's,
you know,
we were on a gold standard.
I mean,
we were on a more pure gold standard before,
uh,
the Federal Reserve came in in 1913.
Uh,
but we were always on some kind of standards.
So the first dollars,
right,
we're receipts for golden silver.
If you go back and you get an old dollar from before,
uh,
you know,
let's say you had a $10 bill,
it would say on the bill pay to the bearer on demand.
$10.
The $10 wasn't a piece of paper that was a representation.
It was an Iou.
$10.
The $10 was the gold.
Uh,
there was $10 worth of gold on deposit and you could it in somewhere.
Fort Knox,
right?
Yeah.
In Fort Knox.
And you could take your $10 to the US treasury and you can say,
give me my dollars.
This is my receipt.
Because it actually was an Iou.
It was a federal reserve note,
even if it was a note,
but it was a note payable in lawful money.
The lawful money was the gold or silver because there were some silver
certificates,
there were some gold certificates,
but there was real money backing the notes,
backing the currency.
That money varied depending upon the price of gold and silver.
Well,
the price of gold and silver,
what your return would be,
but you returned.
There was no.
There never changed.
Yeah,
there was real value.
And when we had real money,
we had prices that went down a little bit every year because money gains value
when it's legitimate.
But our monies illegitimate.
How does he ever recovered?
Well,
it's now counterfeit.
What happened in 1971 when we went off the gold standard,
right?
The government basically repudiated it's promises.
So instead of the $10 bill saying,
we'll pay to the bearer on demand $10,
it just says $10.
You know,
it's,
it's not,
you know,
it,
it's Kinda like if I,
if I go to a coat check and I give them my coat and they give me a little claim
check and says I owe you one coat.
Right.
You know,
the claim check is just a receipt for the coat.
The coat check has.
But imagine if you went down there and you gave him your claim check and they
just crossed out the,
you know,
I owe you one coat and they just gave you back your receipt.
That said one coat,
here's your coat.
That's not my coat.
Well it says one coat.
It doesn't matter what it says.
It's not a coat,
right?
The $10 bill,
just because it says $10.
It's not $10.
It used to represent an Iou for $10.
Now it's just a piece of paper with writing on it,
but it doesn't represent anything.
But right now all we have is this Fiat money,
which means just,
you know,
let it be made.
It's just paper money.
And the founding fathers when they established means let it be A.
Yeah.
Just let him car the car company.
That means let it be made.
Uh,
I don't know,
maybe I don't know,
but that's where that comes from,
the Latin word.
But,
but it's not like paper.
Money is new,
right?
They had paper money before the United States existed.
In fact,
we experimented with it in the continental congress.
They issued something called the continental which collapsed and they had an
expression not worth a continental.
So people like George Washington and Thomas Jefferson and John Adams and
Benjamin Franklin.
These guys hated paper money with a passion.
They knew how evil it was and how dangerous it was.
They didn't want any paper money in the United States.
They wanted us to be on a gold standard.
And so we had a metallic standard with gold,
golden silver,
and it's served our country very,
very well.
But unfortunately we did not listen to the wisdom.
We forgot the wisdom of the founders.
And now we have the exact same,
the exact kind of Fiat money that the founding fathers wanted to make sure we
never had because they knew what a disaster it would be.
And we are going to have a disaster because we don't have real money.
We have,
you know,
this phony money Fiat money and it is,
the
root cause of a lot of our economic problems.
If we had honest money,
we wouldn't have these problems.
We wouldn't have this enormous government,
we wouldn't have all this debt because it would be impossible for the government
to have all this debt if they had a bar of gold.
It is quite impressive when you look back at what the founding fathers predicted
and what they were trying to ward against and,
and protect us against.
And what an amazing job of predicting it.
They were very enlightened men.
They were very learned man.
A lot of them himself,
self educated,
some went to colleges too.
But you know,
and this is,
you know,
they,
they were very,
very bright man.
And so unfortunately with all the population we have now,
I mean there's no way that Congress today can come even close.
I mean,
maybe there's a couple of guys,
but I mean it's nothing like it because we only had 3 million people back then
and we had such an intelligent,
a group of men in Congress compared to now we're drawing off of $250 million and
we have a bunch of idiots.
Okay.
What do we do about that?
There's,
there's no Fort Knox anymore.
There's no big fat pile of gold.
Well,
you know,
well,
we know that money go.
Why don't we claim that there is a bunch of gold there,
but you know,
it's interesting that Germany,
which you know,
we the United States in addition to our own goals,
right?
We also store gold on behalf of a lot of other countries.
So Germany a year ago asked for half of their goal back,
they told the United States government,
we want half our goals and we basically told Germany,
okay,
but it's going to take us eight years to give it to you.
Why?
Because we've got to dig it out of the ground.
Now.
Meanwhile,
it's been a year and we haven't even come close to giving them one eighth of it.
Fucking mouth.
How about that?
He makes some nice cars.
Let's leave it at that.
Don't get crazy.
You guys are about that,
but you know,
they want their gold back because I think they just,
they don't trust this.
Ours mine when they die because it really,
that's why.
Look,
you know,
I think people know I own,
I own a lot of gold.
Are you one of those guys?
You're golden.
Dried food.
Well,
you know,
I got more golden dried food,
but you know,
I think,
look,
I think gold.
I think gold is going a lot higher.
That's why I have a gold company.
You know,
I still,
you know,
your specific precious metals is my goal company,
but I recommend that people own gold.
I own goals.
I want a lot of gold mining gold.
You were like fat chains around the house.
I got a little gold in my watch.
I mean I'm not very flamboyant or anything like that.
Oh No,
I'm not a good thing to have.
If the shit hits the fan,
well,
I mean,
you know,
it's,
it's definitely valuable.
I don't wear my gold.
I haven't,
uh,
you know,
in a,
in a safe.
Okay.
So our money is not backed in gold.
There is no more Fort Knox.
We don't know what happened to all that.
Well,
I don't know.
I don't know if it's there.
It's not there.
I mean,
you're the guy,
but how am I supposed to ask me some questions about martial arts?
Some definitive answers yet,
but I've never been down to about an economy.
I said no,
no,
but I don't know.
I've never been there.
I don't know.
You know,
there are people who have wanted an audit of Fort Knox but they haven't had one
mean.
The government claims that the gold is there.
I hope it's there.
Oh Jesus.
But you know,
as a gold investor,
I,
you know,
certainly if it's not there the price of gold is going to go a lot higher
because eventually the world is going back to a gold standard.
I mean,
there is no question in my mind that we will be back on a gold standard,
not because we
want it right.
The politicians will never want it,
but they're going to be forced to adopt it because it's gonna be the only way to
end the chaos.
But you know,
it's like a chaperone at a,
at a high school prom,
right.
I mean,
the kids don't want the chaperone there.
Gold is the monitor wall.
Fuck yeah.
And the central bankers.
The government wants to fuck us,
but they can't do it on a goldsmith.
Right.
They can't do it when we're on a gold standard.
That's why they don't want it.
That's why they want funny money.
Right.
And the mean to me,
is this,
your advice has nothing to do with the fact that you actually sell gold?
No,
no.
I sell goal because I believe in it.
I believe say I believe I'm going to see.
I want to do the right thing for my clients.
Clients.
Yeah.
If,
if I,
if I thought that they should own something else,
I mean,
oftentimes,
you know,
it's easier to sell people what they want than what you think that they need.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I actually built my brokerage business really in the late 19 nineties when
everybody.
I talked to one of tech stocks and I used to spend all day and all night trying
to talk people out of those stocks.
St Luke,
this is a bubble.
You don't want to buy this,
this is what you need.
You should buy this,
you know,
this company or this dividend,
and,
and it was difficult.
A lot of my friends were making a lot more money than I was back then because
they were just selling their clients what they want it.
But I,
I,
I make a lot more money than they do now because I took a longterm approach.
I wanted to do what was right for my clients,
not what made me the money in the short run.
I was concerned about my reputation and building a lasting business beyond the
tech bubble,
you know,
and I in and you know,
it made it hard for me in 98,
99 and 2000,
but you know,
and in it,
but now I'm getting the same kind of thing again.
You know,
we're now a lot of people are buying these social media stocks and you know,
they're,
they're succumbing to the hype.
Again,
it's,
there's a lot of similarities between what's going on now in the markets and
what was going on in the late 19 nineties.
You know,
people forget the past.
They keep reliving it.
Even if it's recent,
you know,
it shows you how,
how worthless our schools are.
I mean the history,
not only don't they know,
you know,
history of fifth year,
100 years ago,
people don't even know history from five or 10 years ago.
That's how ignorant they are.
What do you think about bitcoin?
What do you think about cryptocurrencies?
What do you think about emerging?
Yeah.
Look,
there are a lot of people that are libertarian or some people that believe in
hard money.
There are people that believe in goal that,
that are in Bitcoin and you know,
I think that a lot of people who bought bitcoin a few years ago and you know,
I didn't buy it and sure,
you know,
I wish I had bought them because I would be selling them now.
In fact that would have already sold them.
So jumped in already.
Oh yeah.
Because I think it's,
I think it's a bubble.
I think that I think that are going to be collapsed here with Vegas casinos to
casinos just started accepting bitcoin.
Yeah.
But you know,
I think merchants starting to accept bitcoins are actually going to be negative
for bitcoins.
Non Positive.
Well here's why.
You know,
when bitcoins went up from Penny's a coin to a thousand dollars,
right?
Do you know you,
you really couldn't do much with them except Horta.
So before you go there,
I'm sorry,
sorry to interrupt you,
but explain to me what is it actually worth?
What is a bit coin is worth whatever somebody will
give you for it.
I mean it has no actual value because you can't do anything with it.
All you can do is give it to somebody else.
So what is it in ones?
It means it in one bitcoin to bitcoin.
What is the volume?
What is the.
They usually sell them into one bitcoin,
but you can bake.
You can break a bitcoin up into like 100,000 pizza.
But.
Okay.
But give me,
how much is the pizza?
How many bitcoins is a pizza?
Well,
a fraction because right now an entire.
Well an entire bitcoin right now is what?
Nine hundred and $50.
So how many pizza you can get?
A pizza is like $9.
Fifty cents.
So you get like 100 pizza.
They didn't have any other thing other than a bitcoin.
That's it.
It's just a bit coin.
Well,
I mean you can get bitcoin.
I mean you can get,
you know,
fractional coins.
You don't have to buy a whole coin.
You have to figure it out.
You have to have like Nicole quarter.
No,
it's just bitcoin.
You could have a decade,
a decade coin is sent a coin,
I don't know what the exact opposite of pesos,
like a million pesos dollar,
but the important thing is that you can't do anything with it.
You know,
there's no actual value.
We think about drugs right now.
Yes,
but you,
you can spend it as long as somebody is willing to take it.
Right.
But there's no end user.
There's no.
It's not a commodity like the same with our currency.
Currently the currency is crap.
I mean I might,
you know why bitcoin is crap in our currency is the difference between the crap,
the government issues and bitcoins is the crap the government issues for now as
legal tender.
I can,
you know,
people will accept it.
I can pay my taxes in it.
I mean I have a use for it,
right?
But it's the government is saying it's legal tender.
The government enforcing being someone who's so antigovernment as you.
I would assume that that's why own gold,
but you would enjoy something like bitcoin.
Bitcoin has,
but it has no real value.
I recognize that it could collapse.
I don't.
There's no agrees there's a value.
Isn't there a value just like we do tomorrow?
Everybody can agree.
There's no value.
See,
gold was valuable long before it became money.
Bitcoin had no value until it became money,
but I don't think it can withstand the test of time.
I don't think it represents a store of value,
but let me tell you why you say that though,
but it isn't like we don't.
We're not on the gold standard right now.
I know our dollars are essentially just like bitcoin.
Well,
they're not just like it,
but not be.
Well.
The government won't accept bitcoins in payment,
in cash.
The motherfuckers.
Okay.
Then eventually,
let me tell you though,
if you go,
if I go to a store that accepts dollars and I pay with dollars,
right?
They don't sell my dollars.
They use their dollars to pay their employees their wages.
They use their dollars to pay their landlord the rent.
They use their dollars to pay their salary.
The employer,
the owner of the business takes the dollars,
pays his mortgage.
He pays his tuition for A.
I mean everybody uses it.
Here's what's going on with bitcoin.
So a merchant decides to accept Bitcoin,
they don't price their products in bitcoin.
What they do is they allow you to pay with bitcoins using bitpay,
but then what they do with those bitcoins,
the minute they get them,
they sell them.
Okay,
so now the more merchants that accept bitcoins,
now all of these bitcoins are for sale.
See,
before when very few people accepted them,
everybody was hoarding them,
and so the reason the price was going up
is because nobody was actually spending were very few people,
but as more and more merchants accept them,
now people take bit coins that they were hoarding and they go to spend them,
but now the merchants want to get rid of them because they need dollars or euros
or whatever their currency is,
who's going to buy them.
Meanwhile,
if you look at Bitcoin for the past few months,
they haven't been going up anymore.
They stopped going up.
I think it's a distribution top,
most likely.
Uh,
and I think the bottom eventually is going to drop out of the market.
I think a lot of people who own bitcoins are gonna.
You know,
the fear is going to take over.
Not The greed right now.
People who have bitcoins,
no,
they,
you know,
they think they're going to become billionaires if they just hold them long
enough,
I think at some point they're going to be worried about losing what they have
rather than getting more.
I think,
you know,
I,
I think they're going to start using them.
They're going to try to get rid of them.
Look,
you know,
I know now is it possible that bitcoin's go to $2,000,
$3,000?
I don't know.
I mean,
sure,
it's possible.
Is it probable viable alternative to the dollar?
Well,
no,
because look,
there's already,
there's,
you go to this website called a coin value.com or some crypto currencies.
There's like 60 or 70 digital currencies that have already been created.
People talk about the fact that,
well,
you know,
there's only 21 million potential bitcoins that can be mined into existence,
but what they don't say is there as an unlimited number of alternative digital
currencies that can be created that are identical,
the Bitcoin,
some might be better than bitcoin.
Um,
and,
and so you can keep creating them.
And,
and so what does that mean?
And you know,
people say,
well,
bitcoin got here first,
therefore it's always going to be the one that everybody wants.
Well,
does everybody use my space?
Facebook wasn't run.
How many cryptocurrencies?
I mean,
do you,
do you use aol is your Internet provider.
I mean they were first,
I mean,
just because you're male,
I mean doesn't mean anything.
This is all a butler,
but,
you know,
to me,
I see a lot of similarities in the people who are irrationally defending,
uh,
you know,
the Bitcoin to what I saw in the Dotcom bubble or the real estate bubble.
Look,
I,
I believe in sound money.
I want to take power away from government.
But,
you know,
I think a lot of people,
if they get into the bitcoin market now they're going to lose a lot of money,
even if it goes higher first.
I think eventually it goes down.
Now I know there's a lot of people that got in early who have a vested interest
in expanding the market so they can sell,
they can cash out and,
and,
and actually convert their paper wealth into real things that they want to buy.
Um,
and you know,
I know it makes me unpopular with some people because they,
you know,
they want me out there,
they want everybody in the hard money community,
you know.
But you know,
I am an equal opportunity bubble spotter.
I mean I'm not going to let my ideology get in my way,
you know.
So if I see a housing bubble,
it's a bubble,
you know,
if it looks like it looks like a duck and it walks like a duck and quacks like a
duck,
it's a duck.
I don't care if I have something
philosophically in common with people who are anti fed,
you know,
wanting to.
I just don't think that the bitcoin now,
if you get a real digital currency backed by gold,
you know,
I can be on board with that because if you go back,
the original paper money,
right was backed by gold and it was issued by private banks,
not in government.
It was like the original warehouse receipt from a Goldsmith and they,
they had your gold and they would issue an Iou and the.
And it would circulate.
It would be a substitute for my.
Have a stockpile of gold somewhere.
Yeah,
we have.
But you'd have something real,
you know,
right now you don't know.
So you know,
you,
you can't put your savings into bitcoin or the thousand dollars.
There's no history of value to bitcoin.
I mean,
how much does bitcoin worth,
you know,
they mentioned some guy you know,
sells,
you know,
bought a house for $7,000,000 worth of bitcoins.
Well,
are you going to accept,
you know,
7 million bitcoins for your house?
I mean,
how do you know what those bitcoins will be worth next year?
Like,
yeah,
I sold my house for this pile of bitcoins.
The only reason you'll do that is because you can dump your bitcoins on the
market and get something else.
There's no,
there's no real frame of reference.
And this is very recent though,
and very new.
Is there just a few years old will the dollar bill is how old?
Well the.
Well the ones that are not backed by nothing started in 1970.
That like looking at a baby and go,
this little motherfucker is not going to be shit.
He can't talk.
He doesn't know how to change.
The only reason amount to anything,
but the only reason the dollar worked for awhile,
not backed by gold and it hasn't worked very well is because it had a history of
being backed by something.
So the public was kind of fooled.
They were using currency backed by Ronnie.
It's not anymore.
Maybe this bitcoin baby grows up.
He's going to realize this dollar that everybody's been.
Hold it over.
My head as being superior is just older.
Yeah.
Well look,
if you some old asshole that just happens to be a dad but doesn't know fucking
Jack Shit about the way the world runs and he's telling you how to live your
life.
Meanwhile he's a fucking mess.
Maybe bitcoin's going to grow up.
Maybe bitcoin's a little baby that doesn't know shit now,
but one day bitcoin's going to grow up and realize,
you know what?
There's a better way.
Well,
I think that it's the people buying them that,
that would grow up.
But you know,
there is you,
you have people get used to it.
Like if you look at the money that we have now that change,
you look at a quarter,
right?
You know,
you think,
you know,
if you look,
if you look at the ridges of a quarter at the side of a quarter,
you'll see that it's,
you know,
it's got,
it's,
it's got these ridges on the sides.
And people said,
well,
why are they there?
Why are there these ridges and why is a quarter even silver in color?
Because it's,
it's,
it's mostly,
you know,
it's mostly made of copper and it's coated with a little bit of zinc,
but why does the government go through the process of,
of,
of binding zinc to copper and why do they go through the expense of making all
these little ridges on the sides of the coin?
Well,
it's because the coins were originally made a silver and they read the ridges
were there so you couldn't shave that you couldn't flip the coin because when it
was valuable silver people would try to take some of the silver off the coin and
then spend it.
But when.
But when the government,
nobody is going to clip the cops on why those old coins are always fucked up and
they never like totally circular.
See like old Roman poet.
So they'll just worn out,
worn out
slightly.
It's a Roman coin.
It's worn out,
but you know,
but when the government originally made a quarters,
when they took the silver out,
they made it look like the old silver coins,
even though there was no silver in there.
It was like people were used to silver coins.
And so when the government debase them,
which is,
that's where the word the comes from the roads or Roman is when the Romans,
you know,
debase their currency by putting base metal into the currency instead of gold.
Right?
So,
but they,
they dumb you down over time.
But now our money is just tokens.
So we don't have any real money.
And we have Fiat,
we have counterfeit paper,
we have tokens for coins,
we have,
you know,
we have this monetary system that is the root cause of all the problems that we
have.
And I think it's all coming to a head.
I think,
you know,
we're at the end of the game now and it's about to blow up and you know,
the 2008 financial crisis.
That was the beginning of the end.
It wasn't the end of it right there.
Real,
real crash is coming.
That's why,
you know,
if you go and look at my book,
the book that I wrote,
crash proof that came out in February.
Oh seven.
The crash that I was writing about isn't the one that happened in 2008.
Even though I predicted that crash,
the crash that I was worried about was the one that's coming,
the one that was going to be a consequence of what I knew the government was
going to do to artificially stimulate the economy after the 2008 financial
crisis I was,
I was against the government bailouts and the stimulus before the government
even knew they were going to do it because I knew exactly what they were going
to do and unfortunately I was right about that.
And that's,
you know my book that's out now,
my most recent book,
other than the one I just gave you on how an economy grows on why crashes the
real crash
south that's coming.
Take a breath.
We're not going to buy your book how an economy grows and when it crashed and
why acquired crashed,
how an economy goes and crashes.
Peter Schiff,
s,
c,
h,
I f,
F,
quiet,
go to Amazon right now.
You fucks.
Alright.
So we've,
we've figured out a lot of things.
We figured out Fuck Lake Michigan.
Well,
that scenario until off lake.
I Love Lake Michigan,
don't get me wrong.
Okay.
Um,
for the Department of Public Education or Department of Education,
Department of Energy,
the government itself needs to shrink down.
We need to have a gold based economy.
Is it possible based monetary system,
but gold based,
right?
We've got to follow the founding fathers,
not the guys in Congress now.
What do you don't know what they're talking about?
Well,
the thing about a resource based finances,
what it is,
is it possible to have other resources and have our economy base or finances
based on other resources.
I mean not,
not really.
I mean I think the reason that gold became money,
and remember government didn't make gold money.
I mean the people made gold money and,
and governments just recognize that fact is because gold was a better suited,
right?
It was a better commodity to serve as money than any other commodity originally.
Get people to give up things for gold though.
But people donkeys worth a lot
of things with your donkey.
Had someone give you stupid piece of metal,
but people only.
We'll always valued gold all around the world.
I don't know because it's pretty because it's,
you know,
it's,
it's very,
it's a very good metal because it's very good,
it's malleable,
it doesn't tarnish,
you know,
like if,
if there's a Spanish ship that sinks,
you know,
you can,
500 years ago if you could find the gold,
it's in perfect condition and they have fairly rare,
but it's also,
you can take goal then you can,
you can,
you can make things out of it because it's very easy.
You can,
you can smash it down into a very thin strip.
Very fine pieces.
So it's good for jewelry is good for,
you know,
you can make dishes.
Yeah,
I mean there's a lot of things that it's useful for.
But even before we had electronics,
it was a symbol of wealth,
right?
You,
if you were wealthy,
you had gold,
either you wore gold or you had it in your house,
you had gold vases or you had gold,
you know,
and you know,
in,
you know,
gilded wood.
You know,
golden was just,
you know,
people valued it everywhere and,
and,
and you can trade it and then it became money because people realized that,
you know,
whatever you,
whatever you needed you can pay for it with gold.
Even if you didn't need the gold,
you know,
you can give it to somebody else who,
who valued it.
And it's scarce.
It's not like there's gold everywhere,
you can't just trip over it.
So it's rare.
And,
and people like it
find a new pocket of gold though and it's worth.
But they have,
but they're not going to,
you know,
like they found this under water,
fresh water,
water lake in Antarctica under the glaciers.
Gigantic freshwater lake and the size of an ocean.
What if they dig in,
they find some gold somewhere and like,
ah,
shit,
gold is like aluminum.
It's everywhere,
but they haven't,
they haven't done it yet.
They're not know there.
And people saying,
well,
devil's advocate kind of guy.
Peter Schiff,
people.
You got people saying,
you know,
maybe there's gold in outer space.
You know,
maybe those golden astronauts.
Yeah.
Well,
how expensive is that going to be to get?
you know,
that's the,
the,
the fringe conspiracy theory of why we like gold in the first place.
And that's to do with the Annunaki.
Do you know the whole story of Zechariah Section?
Do you know who that guy is?
Nope.
VIVICA's,
he shouldn't,
I shouldn't even tell you,
but he,
uh,
he,
he wrote a bunch of series of books,
deciphering the Sumerian text,
you know,
the oldest written language that we're aware of.
And one of the things that he believes the Sumerian texts depicts is that the
Annunaki or this race of beings that created human beings and they live on a
planet that's an elliptical orbit that comes around near Earth every 3000,
600 years.
And they need goal to sustain their atmosphere.
They suspend particles reflective because they've ruined our atmosphere
atmosphere,
sort of like the way we've ruined ours,
like suede China's fucking up.
Well,
they created a bunch of computers over there and they fucked up their atmosphere
too.
So they have to come over to the RF,
take gold.
And that's why we've always used it as current,
but I,
I look like,
but I would,
I would surmise this creative,
my guess would be,
and I'm sure there's intelligent life on other planets.
We're not the only planet to evolve the way we did,
but I bet that you know,
if there's intelligent life on other planets,
that they're going to value gold.
If you can somehow go to another planet,
if you can bring gold,
you can probably buy something.
If you brought a bunch of paper,
Federal Reserve notes,
no one's going to give you anything for them.
Do you think there's intelligent life on other planets?
It's a million years ahead of us.
They have currency and it's based on gold.
Well,
I mean ahead of us.
In what way?
That everything,
they've been alive longer.
Well,
you know,
but just because they've been around longer doesn't mean that they've advanced
more.
But if they have advanced more,
chances are they do have sound money.
Because I do think that if you have free markets and sound money,
you're going to achieve a lot more.
And I can only imagine how much more we would have achieved in America had we
had,
we had more freedom and sound money,
uh,
for the past several decades.
I mean,
I think it would be night and day where we would be assigned from aliens to free
market.
Peter Shift says aliens equal free market if they're advanced.
Imagine what you would do with bigfoot.
No,
no,
that's,
that's if they're advanced.
I mean,
there,
there could be a aliens that are living in the stone age,
you know,
there,
there might not be,
I don't know.
I mean,
I know,
look,
nobody is advanced enough to get here,
right?
No one,
no one's visiting us or at least I guess if they are that advanced,
they're advanced enough to not let us know that they're here.
But,
uh,
so all these people that are talking about Ufos are liars.
Is that what you're saying,
Peter Schiff?
Well,
they might have a vivid imagination.
Most likely.
Likely.
I'm with you.
I mean,
you know,
unfortunately,
but it's not impossible.
I mean,
I,
I'm not going to be naive to think that out of all of the,
uh,
you know,
billions of stars and the billions of planets that may be orbiting those stars,
that we are the only one that evolved intelligent life.
So that's probably not the case,
but you know,
there's certainly the vet,
the universe is vast and the distances that you're talking about are vast and
whether we'll will ever be able to,
you know,
navigate them as you know.
I,
I don't know.
Well,
what do you think about the successful cultures that haven't relied on resource
based economies or haven't relied rather on?
What do you mean by resource base?
I mean by explain like obviously we're dealing with primitive tribes and people
that live in indigenous culture.
It's like saying the rain forest or what have you.
Then their,
their economies not really based on money.
It's not based on gold.
It's based on what they can get from their environment.
Their lifestyle rather is based on what they can get from their environment.
How they stay alive in their happiness is,
is based entirely on what they can get out of their,
their,
their atmosphere.
What are the world that they live in the jungle or what have you.
I mean,
isn't that like a more efficient and more natural way to live and the way we're
living now with these propped up ridiculous economies,
right?
Well,
the way we're living now,
well,
the way we're living now is not natural because we have all this government that
we don't need,
but we're talking about a primitive society.
I mean the only way and that's why he just how an economy grows and white
crashes.
I start this book off three guys living on an island and they've got nothing.
That's exactly what I was asking.
And so this is where it starts because you know,
they're,
they're fishing by hand and the way they,
they.
The first improvement is somebody in Benson net,
you know,
and somebody comes up with a net that can catch more than one fish a day,
but the way humans advance is they come up with capital.
They come up with equipment that can increase their productivity so that they
can produce more stuff with less effort.
That's the only way that we can improve our standard of living is to find ways
to,
uh,
you know,
to create tools.
I mean,
if,
if humans never had any tools but we would still be living like chimpanzees or
even chimpanzees have tools,
but I mean,
but you know,
not a lot but they never had the rights,
but at least they got something they got to stick,
but,
you know,
but the reason that we have,
an advanced societies because we have tools because we were able to improve upon
our hand if all we had as humans was what we can do with our bare hands.
If that's all we could do.
I mean,
we can only eat well,
we can kill with their bare hands and we can,
we would,
you know,
I mean,
what could we.
Well,
it's an interesting example because a lot of indigenous cultures have tools.
They've actually created a team other how to create those tools.
That's how they.
Well,
money was an invention.
Am I asking this question?
The purpose was if you were going to go to a culture,
say like the native Americans when the Europeans arrived and say you weren't an
asshole,
he didn't give him polio and diseases and you didn't kill them all.
If you were going to try to create an economy from scratch based on people who
are essentially living off the land,
how would you go about doing that?
Well,
the first one,
remember the native Americans,
they had money.
They had wampum.
What was wampum?
Shells.
Yeah.
So they hadn't,
they had money.
They had essentially bullshit,
but
nobody,
they value them.
They were pretty,
they were gay.
Could make necklaces out of them.
I mean,
but,
but was,
did wampum,
was there like a pile of shit?
They were like,
oh,
money.
Money is a great invention because without money it's all barter.
Barter is an inefficient way to organize an economy because too much times based
on doing that and not enough gets done.
Right.
I mean,
look,
I mean we'll look,
you've got your podcast,
right?
And let's say you've got,
you know,
and,
and podcasts as me,
right?
But I mean,
you say you have sponsors,
they,
they pay you money,
uh,
and then whatever they pay you.
But if you had a barter,
we'd have to find a sponsor that actually had the actual thing that you wanted
coconut water instead of free,
right?
But instead of money,
money makes transactions a lot more efficient and money allows for loans because
I can loan you money,
you can pay me back so we can have capital investments.
I can,
you know,
economies of function much more efficiently with money than through barter.
So money was an improvement.
It was an advancement,
just like,
you know,
plumbing was an advancement or electricity was an advancement or you know,
the wheel was a great investment.
All these things,
money was a great invention of mankind that allowed for a more efficient
allocation of resources a better,
you know,
distribution,
uh,
of labor,
you know.
So if you say,
if you take money away from a society,
you're gonna make that society less efficient and less productive.
And so that people are going to have a lower standard of living.
Peter Schiff,
you're a bad motherfucker,
but we're at a time.
You didn't do this for about a thousand hours,
couldn't you?
You can keep going.
I can do this with you.
You got plenty of Scotch there so we could get liquored up and might eventually
have to take a bathroom break.
It would be something that would have to happen.
But listen,
I really appreciate you.
Enlightening us.
I really appreciate you tolerating my devil's a questionary.
Uh,
I think that this is a,
this is a fascinating episode for a lot of people because a lot of people like
me are very uneducated when it comes to finances,
don't really understand it and never really have the opportunity to sit down
with a guy who knows as much as you do.
So I really thank you very much for that.
I really appreciate it.
Oh,
a lot of fun.
I appreciate it.
Coming on.
So a follow Peter Schiff on twitter.
Go to his youtube page.
What is your youtube page?
It's called the shift report.
The shift report is fantastic.
I have watched many videos myself,
but yet I am still retarded,
but I'm learning,
I'm trying and I've learned a lot today I think.
I think this has been very enlightening for me and for a lot of people.
So,
uh,
that is the best way to follow you.
The shift report on Youtube.
But you know,
I do a radio show radio.com.
I do two hours a day,
five days a week.
Oh,
people can listen live from 10:00 AM to noon eastern time.
Uh,
they can just subscribe because they can become a premium member.
there's a free trial they can try or that you know,
that you could just listen to anytime because whenever I do a live show,
we then repeat the broadcast for 24 hours until the next live show.
So if you can't listen live,
you can just go to shift radio.com.
And just listen@yourleisureshiftradio.com.
Educate Yourself,
ladies and gentlemen,
understand how you've been fucked and then live the rest of your life in a
paranoid frenzy.
Trying to prepare yourself for the imminent demise that Peter Schiff is
described.
There is no escape.
Be Nice to your neighbors.
Collect water,
find a nice stream.
Learn how to hunt and fish.
All right.
We love the fuck out of you people and we'll see you next week.
We have a lot of podcasts.
Shit coming at Ya.
Uh,
this weekend I will be in Chicago at the Chicago theater Friday night with Ari
Shaffir.
Does a few tickets still available.
And then the weekend after that I'm at the Grande ballroom in New York City and
that shit is sold the fuck out.
We will be talking about bitcoin on Monday with an actual expert,
unlike myself,
Andrus,
and to not pull us.
He knows a lot about bitcoin and he's going to be pissed off at Peter Schiff.
He's going to be really fucking mad
we ever got into a Bama care.
We forgot.
Yeah.
Obamacare.
It's round two will be obamacare.
Thanks to squarespace.
Thanks to all the people that won the squarespace contest.
You will all be contacted and you will get a free year of squarespace and a
higher prime eight tee shirt and a bunch of swag and a on a.com o n n I t use
the Codeword Rogan.
Save 10 percent.
We'll see.
See you guys tomorrow,
next week,
whatever it is.
Can I.